Elon Musk in a bold tweet says Twitter
has interfered in elections and then
everybody started freaking out breaking
news confirmed even The timcast Newsroom
published the story Twitter has
interfered in elections breaking Elon
Musk confirms and I'm like hold on hold
on is he just talking about Hunter Biden
is this like we all know that was
interference or is he talking about
something deeper behind the scenes
I think the answer is deeper behind the
scenes to be completely honest it may be
the hunter Biden stuff it may not be as
profound as a lot of people think it is
but considering that Elon Musk has vowed
to release the Twitter files and has
explained there has been serious
suppression of speech I'm willing to bet
behind the scenes you've got people
working at Twitter in slack and other
other chats explicitly talking about
individuals they want removed for
political reasons but that's just my
speculation
so we will uh we'll talk about that
what's going on with Elon the EU is
threatening to pull Twitter because he's
got to follow the hate speech rules in
Germany they actually raid people's
houses and just did for posting naughty
words on the internet that's just so
creepy man and then um I mean it might
be dystopian to think about but in San
Francisco they wanted the city wanted to
clarify
although they are allowing robots to use
deadly force they won't have guns
they'll have explosives I'm not kidding
I didn't believe the story when I
thought someone made a fake headline as
a gag it's real they're going to equip
robots with explosives
to kill people
wow I didn't have that on my 2022 bingo
card but I guess we're living in a
simulation before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member click that beautiful join us
button and support our work directly we
could use your support
I had a phone call with Google to talk
about section 230 reform that's coming
and they canceled it today and we'll
talk about that too they canceled that
so no maybe it was because I was ranting
enraged that's a that's a little bit of
an exaggeration I was certainly talking
to their rep about all the things
they're doing that they shouldn't be
allowed to do so we'll talk about 2 30.
because it's remarkable how very few
people actually understand the problems
I've got some conservatives saying like
section 230 should be repealed and I'm
like no that's bad then you've got
others saying section 230 is perfect
just the way it is like seriously are
you kidding no it isn't and then uh
we'll get into all that stuff my point
is if it were not for you as members we
probably wouldn't be here because
they've been actively suppressing us and
the show probably would never have been
able to get this big
as a member you're supporting our work
we've been getting demonetized it got
worse in the political season no
surprise there they claim that there's
violence in the videos where I'm
discussing polling and and and the
election it's complete lie it's a
pattern of abuse so we're trying we're
diversifying the business that's why we
have timcast.com so smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
more importantly they can try and
suppress this show and everything else
we produce but as long as you share the
video that URL tell your friends about
it there's nothing they can do joining
us today to talk about all of this and
more is Alx
huh great to be here
um I'm Alx online my full name is Alex
Larusso
um so recently I was reinstated to
Twitter Elon musk's Twitter to Twitter
2.0 so he's calling it
um and my one of my first viral tweets
back I actually raised the question
about the hunter Biden laptop and how we
should see all the internal discussions
come out and less than an hour later he
replied to it and said this is necessary
to restore the public trust so you're to
your point about election interference I
feel like that's what he's directly
going to be talking about there but I
can I can say that there are other
things behind the scenes so that's in
the past week my been my life is being
back to Twitter but so so what do you do
yeah my professional career I am Benny
Johnson's executive producer for his
Newsmax show and also his podcast so
that's what I professionally do Twitter
is more of a Hobby and more for fun for
me right on well thanks for coming man
we also got Luke of course welcome back
to the Cesspool that is social media my
name is we are change.org today I'm
wearing my uh fauci The Grinch Who Stole
normal life shirt great at holiday
parties which you could get on the best
politicalshirts.com and of course with
everything happening right now in China
these days we should remember that Bill
Gates Klaus Schwab Dr fauci are all
literally on the side of China rooting
for them and uh hoping that this happens
to the rest of this world I think it
needs to be pushed back done this is one
way to do it the best
politicalshirts.com thanks for having me
I think this Twitter stuff is big news
I'm Ian Crossland you don't know already
what's up everybody Alex good to meet
you man and I'm glad you're here we have
Benny on about a month ago or something
great show I love the guys so yeah cool
stuff looking forward to getting deep
and I am search.com what's up guys high
energy yeah high energy always all right
let's get to this story ladies and
gentlemen from timcast.com breaking
Twitter has interfered in elections Elon
Musk confirms Twitter 2.0 will be far
more effective transparent and
even-handed new Twitter owner Elon Musk
confirmed the Tweet response the outlet
has interfered in elections now let's
slow down there a minute just a moment
ago in the intro to the show we said is
this Hunter Biden laptop stuff because
we know that happened and we all think
that was election interference but Elon
Musk may be talking about something
deeper and I think that's probably true
even if it is just Hunter Biden laptop
you know a scuttlebutt I think when you
have the CEO the owner of Twitter coming
out saying this is how we interpret what
was done here with the with the app not
he Now controls that still says
something in and of itself but just a
moment ago Alx you are mentioning that
uh you think this is something more yeah
I think this is mentioning back to when
he teased the the release of the Twitter
files and yes a lot of people did think
that was referencing the hunter Biden
laptop but I'm hearing from behind the
scenes so I I have here from Ellie
Alexander says that internally it's been
described of years of confessions within
the company's slack Channel and
employees are knowingly subverting the
rules in terms of service and that the
sheer volume hasn't completely been
compiled yet so that's he like initially
wanted to release this all like when he
found it out Elon yes
um but like so let's yeah sorry let's
slow down
um you're saying behind the scenes
there's confessions people who work at
Twitter admitting to intentionally
interfering yes and I think so my theory
would be for suspending accounts you'd
probably have to give a justification
for it so I'm not sure if they attach
the slack chats to you say like their
panel on there
but I would say that they would be a
giving a reason or B they just never
thought this would happen they never
thought that the company would be taken
over so they viewed that as a safe space
for them to have these conversations
what's uh what's uh Ali Alexander's
connection to what's going on Twitter
um he just has um a bunch of tech
connections um similar to mine as well
I've conversed with people that are
close to Elon as well
um and we've been in kind of the same
circles that that way yeah level of
confidence on this information being
correct pretty high pretty high you
think 99 i i as As a matter of opinion
based on what I know about Twitter and
what we've seen over the past few years
I'd believe it outright but we'll see
I'd love to see the documents come out I
think we're going to find out why I
think it was what was it vinjaya that
was crying
yeah I think I think I think we're gonna
find out why uh they were crying in just
a little bit because we have to
understand this interference didn't just
happen in 2020 this has been going on
for a very long time in 2008 right
before the midterm elections a lot of
people got their accounts taken down
like Laura Loomer so we we know that
foreign governments also spied on
people's private DMS we also know that a
lot of private information was hacked so
this is what's public now what's
happening behind the scenes what else
are they doing how else are they
finagling the algorithm what else are
they doing when it comes to bots when it
comes to manipulating people's opinions
when it comes to people going to the
voting box man I think we're going to
find out a lot of crazy stuff very soon
yeah I spent about five years moderating
as an administrator at mines and
basically with this kind of power and
control and unless you've done this job
you don't really I doubt you would
understand the level of power you have
is just a cheap employee you can push a
button and turn someone's account off
and they have no recourse and you know
that and and you can do if you your
emotions are telling you maybe that
violates the rules in this way maybe you
can turn it off and then or you can
upscale it to your supervisor and if
they agree with you you can turn it off
or limit the ideas and see which ideas
and promote certain ideas and demote
other ideas and there's no recourse
you'd never get punished for it it's the
most empowering like intoxicatingly
powerful I don't think humans should
have that level of authority at this
stage I think we need like a crowd
sourced you know Judiciary System in
social media yeah because that power is
absolute when you can control what
people think what what goes into
people's minds that is god-like power
and authority that obviously people are
going to be abusing for their own
personal benefit because how can you not
when you have so many things at stake
here and when you have free speech
standing in the way destroying so many
powerful PR uh campaigns that they've
been trying to sell the American public
on and the public of the world
so it's going to be interesting I mean
that I I think I I think there's going
to be some significant changes because
of this and I think it's going to shock
a lot of people personally what about
you guys uh uh there's definitely going
to be changes
um it was it was so hard to be an
administrator uh for social network
because you're constantly fighting with
your own morals and trying to do what
the terms say
uh that's it's just I that's maybe
that's not an answer to your question of
what's going to happen next I think
what's going to happen next is he's
going to expose everything the
government's going to freak out they're
going to try and shut down Twitter
Twitter's going to turn into an
algorithm instead of a social like
instead of a website if they're going to
decentralize it'll become something that
plugs into other websites to facilitate
inner communication across patterns I
don't know like when has something like
this happened before where it's a it's a
billionaire taking over a company in
this way and then and threatening to to
expose stuff like this so I think what
he's doing is smart though because if
you notice in the past two weeks all of
these things so he reinstates Donald
Trump he says he wants to give Mass
empathy like to all of these accounts
and then also he's saying he's going to
release the hunter button files and in
the same week he's picking a fight with
Apple
two days later he's meeting with with
the head of apple and they're like oh
well they have they had no plans to do
that so that's him just shrunk like
showing his strong arm basically saying
don't mess with me because like I number
one all of this is coming out and number
two like it's gonna look really bad if
you pull us off the App Store like do
you know how bad that would look if
Twitter got pulled off the app store
Apple stock would would drop yeah I
don't know about you know double dish or
anything like that but they get hurt by
it I know especially and then Elon would
make his new phone which would challenge
Apple directly and their Monopoly I I
talked about this a couple days ago the
potential for low earth orbit
um satellite Communications the
possibility with Elon with starlink is
that phones may actually be able to send
texts and make calls over starlink not a
lot of data probably probably very
rudimentary but what we're already
seeing with the new iPhone is that it's
got a two-way satellite tracking of some
sort or SOS I think it has like SOS or
something
so I remember 10 years ago we had I had
a friend who was going to do coverage in
Syria and we bought a two-way satellite
uh texting device it could transmit I
think up to like 120 characters because
the data was so limited and it took a
long time to do and you'd carry it
around and you could send out a use the
app to send out a very simple message
and you could use it to text to tweet so
it was like wow now the iPhone the new
one comes with this like internally
imagine what would happen
if you've got Elon Musk rolling out a
new phone that has rudimentary
Communications texting now why would he
want Twitter well with us with limited
data transference you'd still be able to
tweet you'd be able to communicate
globally over low earth orbit satellite
with just the phone because you can
transmit a few a few a few characters
that makes me feel like maybe it may be
an X phone or something isn't the
working but think about what happens
then there was this great thread that
this dude put up on Twitter where he
said how do you think the intelligence
agencies react to severing everyone from
their grid they've got they've got
um big facilities that wiretap the the
internet cables that go through the
undersea cables Elon puts them all on
his satellite Network and now they've
got to come to him and he controls the
single access point to spying well
that's dangerous we shouldn't have it no
individual should control the action
sure it's a communication yeah but they
but the intelligence agencies do every
undersea cable you think they're not
tapping that data I think they are they
absolutely are or they're trying to and
maybe maybe we're all sitting here like
oh Elon so great we're showing free
speech and what he's really doing is
making an excuse to centralize
Communications so that a single point
for everyone in the world to have all
their data collected and tracked he's
also said that he wants to revolutionize
the DM feature to make it more like
signal so it seems like he's already
trying to replace text messaging there
and then he also says that he wants to
make Twitter into the X app or the
everything app basically
um similar to what they have in China
with WeChat like everything that they
have in there in their life is
centralized in that one app we almost
we'd considered streaming on Twitter I
think it's at the end of the tech
technology right now to handle it yeah
they've had it for for a while so like
if we were to get pulled down on this on
this network YouTube that we would it's
like striking up like Twitter's now the
HBO of Television currently it's really
weird so like they had Periscope but
then they kind of kicked that same same
they did with Vine but they kept the
like infrastructure I guess so you can
go live on it but it's the features are
very limited on it it's just a tweet
with the live video you can't really do
much with it but then they they released
that uh thing today where they said that
they're going to have capabilities of
like two hour uploads or something like
as a hard upload 40 gigabytes 40
gigabytes that's massive two hours
that's right only only for Twitter blue
subscribers though smart oh that's smart
yep wow not first but not for everyone
you know so my question is I tweeted you
know my pitch is on audio video tab rev
share and premium subscriber content uh
abilities which which already exists
with the super follow or the content
subscribers so am I going to spend eight
bucks a month to get access to this to
upload my videos that Elon then has to
pay me for because that seems a little
redundant you know uh it's it's an
interesting model and mine says that too
you sign up for mines Pro and then once
you do you're able to move your mind's
tokens off chain onto your wallet so you
can actually if you want to make money
off mines you got to pay to be able to
make money off mines and that helps the
program are you saying uh you need
Twitter blue to upload and create
two-hour videos or to watch or both
um to upload I think so okay but anyone
can watch yeah I'm pretty sure yeah that
would make sense well I'm open to trying
new networks you know we don't have to
sit on one network forever no this is
going to be crazy yeah I I I think
people need uh Luke you brought this up
he wants to make it like WeChat yeah
yeah I mean we were talking about this
for uh a very long time because he made
similar announcements and speeches
saying everyone depends on almost every
aspect of their life in China based on
this one particular app that they have
to go through for everything their their
jobs their applications their resumes
their food orders their their
entertainment all of that is controlled
in one app that the Chinese government
is watching and controlling and of
course dictating what people can and
cannot say so that's a bad thing right
well it's it's centralized
and think about that if this really does
go in the direction of an X phone and
then we're all getting these phones like
wow they use starlink so I can call and
text and use Twitter and you know can't
watch movies or anything
then that is a singular Network taking
all data if we get to that point where
we're no longer using undersea cables
there's there's definite benefits to it
but then
they're going to spy on everyone
everywhere so what we were just talking
about
um someone just super chatted this and I
double checked it but T-Mobile is
already working with starlink and
they're announcing that they're going to
be connecting their phones to the
T-Mobile network over starlink starting
next year no hell yeah so this is
techcrunch.com and the title of this
article that I just found is T-Mobile
phones will connect to stalling for free
starting
the crystals in there we got the story
just real quick hold that thought in
yeah T-Mobile phones will connect to
starlink for free starting next year and
this is from August you see all we had
to do was Google it we're behind the
times on this one they're going to set
up what's going to happen is you're
gonna be able to call Mars when people
start
um habitating Mars and it'll take two
hours to get your voice message over
there and then they're going to realize
sympathetic vibration and they're going
to put crystals in the satellites and
Chris and it'll create like an
entanglement system not quite
entanglement but where the creates
sympathetic vibration between nodes and
you'll have instantaneous Communications
is this is does he have a bigger master
plan behind all of this how much did he
pay for buying x.com he's had it since
the 90s exactly well I think he had to
buy a website to buy it back right yeah
yeah and he spent like a record amount
of money on that I saw Eli XCOM I wonder
if he played XCOM yeah I saw him he
tweeted cancel culture must be canceled
or something like that right
and I'm like he does say a whole lot of
things that come off as like overly
generic you know he's he's pandering to
the Free Speech crowd
look man he's getting a lot of people to
cheer for what he's building so keep an
eye out man I'm concerned he's in an
echo chamber I've been thinking that
lately like people will tweet at
whatever he's going through they'll
tweet it at him and he'll respond to
that what if I get it that's what he's
going for what if it's a psyop within a
psyop a false flag within a false flag
setting up the media to attack him so he
looks favorable because you know after
after the the the last two presidential
elections we learned when you know the
corporate media attacks you especially
with the rise of Donald Trump they kind
of prop you up so what if this is all
kind of planned and engineered this is
where my conspiratorial mind is going to
right now that we'll end up with our
brain chips on the X app essentially
having a life that's controlled with
satellites watching our every single
move as we are living under you know the
the Tesla production facility of uh
robotic pods and uh bugs provided a few
things to eat the government Elon Musk
is also uh you know you know he's also a
big on global warming he's also big on
world government as well so those are
things that I would just be extremely
skeptical of and this is why again what
Elon Musk is doing is commendable but
there's a small part of me that's
skeptical it's the risk we take as
humans and with our current structure
we'll give one guy so much power to
create a an Empire and then hope that he
doesn't turn on us as humans and over
time you see people turn on people like
they get bought out they get bribed or
they die and someone else takes over the
the Empire so we're in a risky place
with Elon with so much power hopefully
it will evolve into a system instead of
uh a guy's toy I think the only re the
the good thing about having the richest
guy in the world do this though is that
he can't really be bought because at
this point like money is kind of
meaningless and he even said that he he
doesn't want to buy Twitter to make
money because well number one like
honestly once you get to whatever
billion he's at like what is another
billion what is another three billion
he's taking initial losses on this but
he wants to turn the company profitable
um and actually like the terms for x.com
were not disclosed but he bought it back
from pay PayPal in 2017 but yeah so so
what's another like couple billion to
him so that that's the only reason that
I think he's doing it in good faith is
like what does he need more money for
honestly I also want to point out this
TechCrunch article they say at first the
service will only enable text messages
and possibly messaging apps yeah and
Twitter yeah exactly Twitter so people
will be able to engage in the
conversation from the middle of the
Mojave Desert or or who knows where else
Burning Man from burning I'll be
tweeting all the birding Man photos well
you can't do the photos
you'll be able to send it here can't
believe I found them at this Dome with
the crystals you can't believe where he
put him I wonder if the the Free Speech
stuff from Elon is just to Rally people
to support him he was talking about how
a bunch of Democrats all came out at
once started attacking him and I'm
willing to bet that he immediately was
like okay I need some allies so you know
I'm gonna I want to do my thing I want
to build this stuff
okay Free Speech we want Twitter anyway
let's start unbanning people and make
this Talk of the Town
I I I don't know though you know maybe
maybe it's out of the kindness of his
heart the The Good the the the uh the
strong morals he has that he wants to
stand by free speech
and then you read these stories from
back in August you think about the stuff
that he's intended to build people have
already mentioned months ago I think a
year ago that Twitter would be great for
uh interplanetary communication because
you put out a message and it's available
to be seen by anyone anywhere as opposed
to I'm gonna message you and then it's
gonna come to just you yes you can put
out a message it goes to The Ether
everyone can see it when they're
available to see it
I think that's or he's just just having
a good time and there's also I mean
there's also a lot of data and a lot of
information that you could get on the
the general public through Twitter you
could see I I mean there's a reason
intelligence agencies launch campaigns
for civil unrest in foreign countries on
social media and use it as their main
kind of uh rally and call and organize
and call there's a reason
um Apple just got rid of Bluetooth
connection and the ability to airdrop
messages in China a few days ago because
they understand with the Chinese
government controlling
um the cell phone connectivity there
with with them controlling the internet
there the one thing that they don't
control is Bluetooth to Bluetooth
peer-to-peer communication Apple got rid
of that they blocked airdrop yeah
airdrop on beheads of the Chinese
government because this was the main
tool that the Chinese government that
that the Chinese protesters that were
calling for more freedom were using in
order to communicate with each other
without being punished so now the you
know the Chinese police we're literally
going around from person to person
checking their cell phones in the subway
as they were walking walking down the
street in order to stop them from
sharing any kind of information let me
let me show you guys this ridiculous uh
video right here nice uh look at this
strapping young lad from 10 years ago is
that Elliott page right there is that
sweat out that's uh that's me standing
for some reason in a forest wearing a
very tight shirt I guess looking good
and uh I was doing a report on this new
patent that came out it this this is 10
years ago YouTube put it was on the
front page it was on like World Star
Hip-Hop YouTube's old now basically and
I made this like little animation
breaking down how it works and uh they
were they were patenting this technology
that they could go into their Maps
isolate a certain area on the map
geofencing and then if you entered that
portion your phone would be disabled and
they were like oh think about it you
enter a movie theater your camera
doesn't work and everyone's like yeah or
you're at a protest and you can't film
the cops anymore
or you're in China and you're
communicating via Bluetooth and they
turn it off that's crazy to hear that
they're doing it and there was there
were like a lot of people said Tim they
never did this you're wrong it's like
okay man you know it's it's probably not
the same exact thing
but it's creepy that it's it's so
similar I'm not a big fan of apple as a
company I never have been in in the 90s
I thought they were proprietary couldn't
game on their systems you had to get
your own unique power supply all these
unique pieces and parts and then it was
way overpriced uh Steve Jobs brilliant
you know brilliant I don't know profit
you could call him I guess he has great
and they have great design but I do not
like the way that they organize their
company I don't like that they're
they're they're siding with the Chinese
government over the freedom people that
are trying to protest being free of
being locked in their homes but Apple's
gonna side with the people locking them
in their homes meanwhile they made a
huge statement about George Floyd and
all the freedoms that they're fighting
for here in the United States meanwhile
what are they doing in China with the
protests essentially starting at the
foxcom factory facility where you know
the Chinese people were forced to make
iPhones forced to make Apple products so
I believe some people this is the what
really kicked off these Chinese protests
which we probably should talk even more
about is that people were locked in
their homes for covid and and the
building caught fire and like 20 people
burned to death yeah that's one story
out of many horrific horror stories of
but that's what they have Insanity
happening in that country there's videos
of them welding doors again again yeah
yeah there's videos of like them
torturing and beating someone up at
their own home with their children
watching because they criticized the
coveted lockdown policies online there's
so much Insanity there's so many cruel
just absolutely insane videos they were
walking around with sticks beating up
and killing dogs because they thought
that they were spreading diseases this
is the this is the policy that that
Klaus Schwab said is the example for the
world to follow this is the policy that
Bill Gates said this is what we need to
implement here this is what Dr fauci
knew was happening saw the report saw
the investigations and said we need to
implement this here in the United States
and they almost did and they were very
we were very lucky that we have
something called the first and second
amendment and I think that's the only
thing that stood in the way of total
tyranny taking over all of the United
States which I think we were very close
to achieve it you're talking about the
zero covet policy yes look at Europe I
mean they locked down they were much
more harsh Australia we're Australia
absolutely New Zealand I mean you know
what you know what man I you know who I
feel bad for is uh Claire Lehman you
guys know Claire right yeah yeah poor
lady Colette was this you know
intellectual dark web free speech and
then Australia announces they're you
know gonna set up camps where they can
take people against their will to detain
them because of covid call it whatever
you want and people were trying to
escape these places because people
couldn't leave their cubicles and uh
Claire Lehman of quillette this was like
you know Free Speech intellectual
thought all of a sudden it's just like
this is okay lockdowns are good and I
imagine the reason is she's in the
system she is within the walls of the
machine that is doing this to people and
uh if she speaks up she gets thrown in
huh yeah or she gets taken down or they
come after her and she showed that she
was terrified of the machine around
founder either that or she completely
betrayed all of the principles she
espoused before but either way she's
fake and they were literally copying and
pasting the same policies that they were
testing and implementing in China in
China they're still building 90 000
quarantined facilities uh for sorry 90
000 individual boots pods four people to
to live in in major cities all
throughout China so so again these These
are camps that people are thrown in many
times not even for testing uh positive
many times for being around someone that
was maybe sick and other times for
criticizing the government people just
get thrown in these pods as we saw in
Australia people were thrown in there
without any tests without any close
contacts they were just arguing that
police officers the police officers had
had enough saying no two-week quarantine
you're done absolutely insane policies
that's what happens when you give people
power too it's like if they can do that
for kovid or for medical reasons why
can't they do that for disagreement
right and who's who's to say like for
evidence like there there is no evidence
there's you know no one to prove that
they do or do not have covet for
um so yeah and in America I think it
didn't get to that point but like
obviously like vaccine cards and then we
didn't have like the vaccine mandate for
for planes necessarily but like fauci
went on TV saying yeah we're not ruling
anything out like we tried yeah they did
yeah and then I think they saw the
American people resist and it didn't
work because they had the was it the
Excelsior app in New York yeah QR codes
American people were like nope yeah and
then you look we're we have big open
rural spaces so out here in West
Virginia there was basically nothing you
know you're trying whatever you want
you're trying to create some RFID real
life driver's license yeah what's that
that's supposed to come out that's been
out for a while there I have yeah I have
one is there some extreme states is
there some upgrade coming out this year
in the next six months or something I
don't know if it has RFID or what but I
think I think passport cards do though
right yeah I think so yeah so I've got
one of those when you apply for a sports
like your passport card it's a North
American ID and it's funny because I
tell people did you know that there's a
North American ID card and they're like
what you mean like an American like no
no like it's good for Canada the US and
Mexico it's an ID card that works in all
three places yes pass card I think yeah
passport you have your identification
card
um but after the G20 this year all the
world leaders came together and saying
that they need an international vaccine
passport system that they're going to be
implementing for the rest of the world
okay is are we clear now that covet came
and went and now there's like less
dangerous variants out there that people
are just living with I don't think much
has changed honestly
um it's just the propaganda just the
fear that's how we treat it and how
we're talking about it like like when it
comes to doctors and nurses that I talk
to they're like yeah not much not much
has changed except for the fear and
propaganda so except for the gaslighting
except for all the manipulation all the
the the the just fear-mongering of
people saying you're gonna die you're
gonna kill grandma that's over otherwise
people are you know people are getting
sick just like they usually did and uh
but but now they're uh you know dropping
dead suddenly which
um you know oh yeah that died suddenly
documentary people are like there's
evidence that people are having like I
don't know if it's myocarditis they
don't know what but they're calling them
they're calling them white what a guy
called he called white fibrous clot and
we don't know what they are and my
question is for that stuff like have
they have they sent those things to a
lab for sampling to see what they're
made of because it because like what is
that material like collagen or something
yeah I think I think probably most
people watching this have seen that
documentary I think it it jumps the gun
in in a couple of ways and uh but either
way it highlights something really weird
going on yeah well you're not supposed
to from what I've learned growing up
you're not supposed to get vaccinated
for diseases you currently have it's
only you get it before the hand so that
it prevents you from getting it that's
the idea or makes your immune system
more robust if you do but if you have
the disease and then you vaccinate
that's like overdoing
many many many years ago natural
immunity is best you know but but I'm
pretty sure even the covid policy is and
and talk to your doctor about what's
right for you but I'm pretty sure it's
you can't get it if you had covet within
a certain time period like you're not
supposed to get the reasonable doctors
are saying that but the federal
government is not I'm very concerned if
people had coveted large amounts and it
was messing up their their clotting
stuff and then they get a vaccine on top
of that which might also be messing up
that so that's why I I have a question
about this though because uh you know I
I've watched that documentary and it was
uh really well made I mean like the
quality like the Cinematic shots like
from cinematography perspective wow and
there's a lot of really interesting
things that came up uh because of it and
I uh I tweeted that it was a conspiracy
that all these embalmers and doctors got
together and planned to discuss this on
camera I'm kidding right certainly there
is something they're experiencing
something that's happening and I've
showed I've shown it to a bunch of my
friends I'm sure many people did but the
question I have is one we don't exactly
know what's causing this or why we just
know it's something new that embalmers
are seeing and they're not they don't
know what it is and there are some
doctors who are also like they they show
clips of people getting their their
alive there's living people getting
these clots pulled out and they're
calling them white fibrous clots
my my my thought is this
you look at what's going on in China
and they're welding people's doors shut
they are absolutely terrified of covid
you look at what's going on with this
documentary died suddenly in these white
fibrous clots the documentary Paints the
picture as though it's the vaccines I I
don't think we know that I I think
obviously people are saying this this
large wide scale Global thing happened
therefore you know we assume this is the
case and I'm also like yeah but covet
happened too so here's my thoughts and
again I know a lot of people are going
to get mad I'm just let me open and I'll
of course say you know I don't know I'm
not a scientist I'm not a doctor this is
this is you get your medical advice from
people that you trust who are real
doctors but if there's if there's an
ongoing theory that kovid came from a
lab where they're doing experimentation
isn't it possible that what we're seeing
in terms of these blood clots are the
result of some kind of weaponized virus
or the gain of function research created
something so dangerous that China's
reaction is to weld doors shut in fear
of what the virus could be doing well if
you see what the Chinese government was
doing it was never really about health a
lot of this wasn't about health since of
course A lot of these Health policies
actually led to a degradation of
people's Health not only mental health
cognitive speaking skills especially
when it came to small children physical
health mental health all of that went
dramatically down and they knew it would
because there was warnings there was
people saying hey when when you when you
cause this much uh suffering for
Humanity there's going to be larger
consequences and there's even a lot of
Mainline professionals arguing that it
was the lockdowns the the health
restrictions that actually caused more
pain Havoc suffering and death than
actually the the sickness itself there's
also a doctor Asim malhorta Malhotra who
was just on Tucker cross he's a
cardiologist from the United Kingdom he
was actually in the advertisements in
the United Kingdom telling people to
take this particular product
um he had his father die he believes his
father died from that particular product
he's coming out and sharing a lot of
very crazy data and information from his
profession that is connecting some of
these dots again I'm not a medical
doctor I'm not here to give anyone any
kind of medical advice but doctor a seem
Malhotra is making some really
interesting arguments right now and I
don't want to uh rehash all the
conversation so I want to I want to ask
additionally another question well I I
guess it's always rehashing something so
the the thought I suppose is are they
terrified of the virus that's why
they're welding doors shut that's why
they're maintaining zero covid we know
that kovid has uh well I should say it
has been reported covet is more likely
to impact Asians because they have more
ace2 receptors so all of a sudden you
have China just going nuts my other
question is pick and choose your
conspiracy I guess is this the great
reset is it that China has a massive 1.3
billion human population and so
according to those who are trying to
curtail human growth and expansion and
pollution the reason China's in such
heavy lockdown is not covid it is carbon
they have I mean to me it's Psychopathic
totalitarian control because if you look
at the way that the Chinese government
has been operating and who have they
been working with especially when it
comes to a lot of the bigger Elites it's
always been about beta testing the
latest surveillance technology whether
it's the social credit score whether
it's punishing people for thinking the
wrong thing whether it's finding people
and taking money out of their bank
account for jaywalking the latest worst
1984 Vision you can imagine is being
tested right now in China and I think
this goes along with these lockdowns
which are which are continuing this
larger progression that they've been
making against free Humanity I I
definitely think you know we agree it's
dictatorship it's insane I guess my
question is the motivation behind it is
it just to experiment total control or
is there something motivating them
behind it like like uh carbon get carbon
emissions down there's too many people
in this country they want to reduce
population China doesn't give a damn
about carbon China is releasing all the
carbon in the world possibly trying to
name someone else China was being paid
by the Western world to recycle they
literally took all the plastic dumped it
in the ocean this is why there's mild
Long Islands of plastic right now in the
ocean so you could feel better about
yourself if you're in Canada in the
United States recycling literally it's
just being dumped right into the Pacific
Ocean China is launching a lot of coal
factories China does not give a day you
don't see China setting up uh solar you
know a lot of solar facilities you don't
see them setting up wind facilities you
don't see them setting up alternative
green energies they're setting up coal
mines for a reason
um because they understand how the world
Works they're they're tightening their
relations with with Russia which they're
buying a lot of gas and oil from and
then reselling it back to Europe all in
the name of green energy policies
they're they're going into Afghanistan
and Mining all the minerals there so
there's no way that they care about
carbon carbon is just an excuse for more
control of society totalitarian I would
say even satanic uh lockdown and
destruction of the free human Spirit but
is that the motivation then they're just
like I want power but for lockdowns in
general if you if you looked at the
original lockdowns they locked down
almost right away so I'm I'm thinking it
was originally to number one cover up
because instead of asking for help
China's a very prideful country they
don't want to ask for help from other
countries and say we have this problem
they thought they had it all under
control they could lock everyone down
and cover it up so I think maybe that
was the initial motivation behind it but
then it grew into a more hey we can get
away with this
um we have so much control over the the
people because if you think about it
from a medical standpoint too they
probably didn't know what was being
Unleashed they just knew it was
dangerous or whatever and they were just
I think their initial motivation was to
try and contain it and cover it up I
disagree because if that was true they
wouldn't allow international flights if
you remember when you know covert first
hits one there was also intelligence
agencies uh talking to each other in
ramblings and documents coming out that
there was something going on of
September the year beforehand uh before
everything broke out but when China knew
something was going on they closed
domestic travel from Wuhan you couldn't
go from muhan to Beijing you couldn't go
anywhere domestically in China from
Wuhan but you could to Italy you could
to other parts of the world that were
severely affected by this that were
depending also on slave labor Italy was
depending on a lot of Wuhan workers that
were coming in there to make made in
Italy products for for pennies on the
dollar and when you implement a policy
like that you are either sociopathic and
want this disease to spread all over the
world and you want to hurt the rest of
the world or you're just absolutely dumb
I don't think they're dumb I I think
there's a reason that they have very
high intelligence and I think this is a
part of a larger takeover and I think a
lot of this was deliberate from the very
beginning I like the conspiracy theory
that they're like the people that made
it in a lab are like oh no in two years
is when is when the second iteration of
the disease appears in people's bodies
and that's when they're really going to
change so they're freaked out change
yeah but I don't turn into vampires yeah
exactly when you start to see the the
big whites things come out of their
veins and they're like no lock them all
up I don't think that happened but it's
a crazy Theory no no I remember early on
in the pandemic There Was Fear about
multiple stages because uh some I don't
like I'm not a virologist or a
microbiologist or uh any other kind of
scientist or doctor so again talk to
your doctor but there was concern about
um it could come in multiple stages or
go dormant so some viruses you'll get
sick and then they go dormant and then
they can come back later
so we didn't really know what we were
seeing with this maybe uh now people are
getting weird stuff pulled out of their
veins because
because of of multi-stage or something I
honestly don't know the real Vibe I get
is that the CCP is is over the top to I
think totalitarian is the right word and
they just want Total Control of their
population and they want a population
reduction because they have too many men
and they're they're they're not enough
women no no absolutely not uh
what do you mean China has a population
crisis they're doing everything in their
power to try to make sure that they have
more people more women more right yeah
because of the one-time one child
possible that was implemented by also uh
the Rockefeller uh you know Turner Ted
Turner as well and a lot of the American
Elites came there and said you know
let's let's test out Eugenics here let's
see what happens when we force people to
have one child and the Chinese
government said okay just tell us what
to do and I think they're still taking
orders just like they did before that's
a real thing the one child policy I
don't know if everyone knows about that
what was it in the 80s is when this
started I have to double check just to
make sure earlier in the 80s it was
early in the 80s it's crazy and they
were just like you can have one kid and
people would have like a female baby and
they'd kill it because they weren't
allowed to have more than one kid and
they wanted a boy because the boy is the
one who carries the Legacy and they took
it even further when they started saying
if you want to leave China go to Africa
which is happening right now happening
all the time you can have more than one
child if you go to Africa colonization
exactly exactly no one talks about that
yeah China's colonizing like crazy and
people think that colonization is like
this nefarious plan among you know I
should say woke people they're like
colonization the white people came it's
like right they came because it was
getting crowded and they wanted to find
a better life and they took the risk to
do it people in China it's getting
crowded and so they're like you know I'm
gonna go move to another country and
have a family there and that is
colonization yes they're creating you
know little chinatowns which have have
uh actually if you've ever been to New
York it's awesome there's really great
restaurants but the end result is you
start seeing a shift in the culture of
of you know where they end up going
that's what colonization does
I think what we need is Mars
colonization Elon how about it I'm so
excited to colonize Mars
what we got oh you're wearing it there's
this meteor stream that we go through uh
every 1200 000 12 000 years or so it's
called the torrid meteor stream it looks
like it's coming from Taurus the
constellation so we call it the torrid
meteor stickers of Taurus and uh that's
the cow those are the Comets that hit
Earth the meteors that hit Earth 12 000
years ago that ended the Ice Age melted
the you know the the flood myth wiped
out Atlantis wiped out culture well
we're in that toward meteor stream again
for the 12 000 years later we're here
again we're for the next 35 years what
we need to do is redirect those those
meteors into Mars we can do that we can
nudge them start peppering the surface
of Mars with this heat and then start
melting that ice didn't we do a test on
that recently like uh slightly changing
the trajectory of like a meteor yeah it
was called the dart I think it was
called the DART program NASA
um and what they did I think what they
did was they hit it with an explosive
and shattered it I could be wrong
but yeah they're they're avidly working
on ways to move asteroids meteors and
comets
um I don't know if shattering it's the
right move because commentary fragments
can still destroy us I just I just want
to say real quick before we go to the
next segment actually I'm going to say
this right now at the beginning of this
segment it's from the guardian EU raises
Prospect of big final ban if Twitter
fails to follow new legislation because
they don't have free speech in Europe
but what I want to point out is Yo our
our metrics are going really weird like
on YouTube it's like spiking and
dropping like weird stuff's going on and
I want to point out that I was supposed
to have a phone call with Google and
they canceled it had a call with them
yesterday so uh you know I don't trust
these these big tech companies behind
the scenes but uh that being said I
think Elon is doing a tremendous service
to humanity whatever his agenda may be
but of course in Europe they don't have
free speech so what's happened now there
was this uh they posted a video I think
Elon was talking to these EU guys they
say Elon Musk was told he had huge work
ahead to comply with eu's Digital
Services act which requires Tech firms
to tackle problems including abusive
posts and disinformation the eu's
commissioner for the internal Market
Terry Bretton told the Tesla CEO that
Twitter will have to significantly
increase every to pass the grade
implying the platform was in danger of
non-compliance with the ACT I welcome
Elon musk's statement of intent to get
Twitter 2.0 ready for the DSA said
Breton I am pleased to hear that he has
read it carefully and considers it as a
sensible approach to implement on a
worldwide basis but let's also be clear
that there is still huge work ahead as
Twitter will have to implement
transparent user policies significantly
reinforce content moderation and protect
freedom of speech and with that I got a
question what can they do to stop him
how do you ban Twitter find him find him
how
um
this is this is the point I was making
uh I was talking I told the story about
my friends when I was a kid I'm a bad
influence when I was like hey you want
to go skate I can't I'm grounded I'm
like okay well what does that mean it
means I can't go outside
okay what happens if you go outside I'll
get grounded more and what does that
mean it means I can't go outside longer
but you went outside already yeah I know
but I'll get in trouble bro you can go
outside I like very bad influence my
point is if Elon Musk is using starlink
for for communications if he makes his
own phone maybe he said he might if he
has to You Can't Ban apps and countries
in China and Iran they have Twitter even
though it's banned they'll find a way I
was gonna say he's gonna make them be
the bad guy he's going to be making them
be the new China EU is going to be
looked at as like a like a China type
and I've pointed this out on on Twitter
in the past couple days everyone is
freaking out Apple was freaking out and
these countries are freaking out now
about free speech and stuff
um so why are they not freaking out a
couple years ago when they uh Apple's I
mean uh Twitter was being sued for two
different cases and there's I'm sure
there's more of child exploitation
content on the platform those individual
users were complaining to Twitter saying
this is me in the in the videos I am
underage please take this down Twitter
refused to take that content down we
were talking about this a few days ago
exactly what you just mentioned and
where is the EU to go to Twitter a year
ago and be like hey hey these things are
in violation of our laws but now they're
mad this is the statement that the EU
released today that they're mad that
he's going to be arbitrarily reinstating
banned users and that he's not pursuing
disinformation aggressively enough and
that they want a full quote extensive
audit of the platform so they are they
are mad that people are going to have
the ability to have free speech they are
mad that users are going to be brought
back and that they're lies of the state
are going to be officially challenged
this is all about power at the end of
the day the European Union knows the
government bureaucrats knows these
criminals in charge know that they could
only be in power if they could keep
conning and lying to everyone once you
have free speech that power goes away
once you have free speech that is all
threatened all of that could go away and
this is why we're seeing such very harsh
actions by the European Union that did
Levy very big fines against previous U.S
big tech companies like Facebook if you
remember it wasn't so long ago Facebook
had to pay off you know a lot of money
as well to the EU yeah so so so again
Google lost an appeal for for four
billion dollars in EU fines I was I was
taking a dump the other day and Facebook
wouldn't stop calling me true story I'm
not even kidding no and it was really
annoying too because like I play uh it's
I posted it to I posted how Google was
calling me to talk about section 230 and
then a bunch of people were like you
this never happened and I'm like I'll
post this post a screenshot of the email
they sent me and I got like the World
Series of Poker I love playing World
Series of Poker and uh and I'm trying to
play this game and then I get a call
from Facebook and I'm like what are you
like close I don't want to talk to you
they called me three times in like five
minutes super creepy and they were like
we want to talk to you about you know
your marketing stuff and what you're
working on it was like the most unhinged
desperate thing that's ever happened to
me super weird they they it was like a
pitch to like buy ads on Facebook
because we have an account and then they
called me three times in a row and then
it was like that Trope of the voicemail
where it's like oh must have just missed
you uh I'm gonna give you a call back
and and maybe I'll get you again I'm not
getting I'm like what are they doing
it's super crazy home uh well I'll just
I'll just try again yeah more and more
agitated they're seeing the writing on
the wall too because they're like if
this can happen to a company like
Twitter or whatever what's to stop it
from happening to a Creator and Company
like Facebook Mark Zuckerberg has lost
like over half of his net worth yeah his
company is cratering they're making Cuts
everything that that's why I'm thinking
they called me like crazy I'm willing to
bet that they've got you know for their
sales team it's like guys we gotta ramp
this up they light up what like 11 000
people yeah there's the stock price
tanked I guess because of meta or
whatever the plan is that's the other
thing too they're they're demonizing
Elon Musk for making these cuts and then
ignoring Facebook is making Cuts Amazon
is making Cuts all of these things
they're like oh he took over the
platform and he's turning into some
crazy thing I'm like okay it's happening
all over the tech industry if you're
like paying attention right um but the
thing is too about these um these
policies so they stopped enforcing the
covid-19 misinformation policy last week
um and then so my my thing is they're
more likely to be compliant with all of
these legal stuff if there not wasting
their resources policing opinions or
policing coveted misinformation do you
know how much Manpower that would take
and they have the whole report of how
many suspended accounts how many
millions of posts that were actioned of
of covid posts or whatever and I know AI
helps a lot with that type of stuff but
still the resources that are wasted on
opinion and political speech and
silencing dissent rather than actually
going after like child exploitation or
actual legal content on the platform do
you know how much like energy could be
redirected towards actual like crimes on
the platform like it's like
mind-boggling and you mean like illegal
in the United States
well I mean it would depend on the law I
believe for each country because I think
that's what Elon said and then I I know
I'm always confused by this I I see
always this like oh uh someone reported
this uh tweet it's not in violation of
German law or something yeah I see that
I always see that I'm like I don't even
know what that means no but it's a good
thing right so I've gotten these these
emails from Twitter where it's like
you've been reported in Pakistan or
something yeah and I I can't remember
who but someone a conservative said why
am I why is this being shown to me why
why is Twitter concerned about this and
I'm like oh that's a good because then
if you go there you could be arrested
and I'm not I'm not kidding so Twitter
warning you that you've posted something
that they consider illegal is like hey
now you can't go there anymore it's a
good thing they notified you the German
law thing is because German Germany has
a law that they have to inform people so
even if you're outside the country they
have to inform you so the EU is all
sorts of insane
there was this um this video of this
woman she was a uh from the Philippines
I think she was a journalist I don't
know if you saw it where she's talking
with Colbert or something like that and
she's like they're using free speech to
stifle free speech like it's just the
craziest thing but you can really see
what their real agenda is they want to
be the controllers of all information
and have no one else be able to speak
out out of turn of the narrative but the
narrative machine is crumbling and this
is why they were crying when Elon was
taken over those those already the
messages we saw what was it Vijaya uh
she was like she was like Hey we're
gonna work with the government or
something like that we're going to work
with you and get this stuff sorted she's
tied up in that whole lawsuit uh that
they're about like collusion with the
Biden uh Administration
um so that's that's all going to come
out too I think but it seems like she
has her hands in a lot of things because
she's also with the hunter Biden laptop
and she was also the person who banned
Trump so evil people man it's crazy I I
hate to say it but man there's no
accountability you take a look I mean I
I think everybody listening knows you
take a look at what happened with Trump
and the fake impeachment stuff you take
a look at what Joe Biden did they
impeached Trump for what Joe Biden did
it's the craziest thing you take a look
at what the people at Twitter were doing
and you're like just where is a single
moment of accountability
Lane Maxwell okay fine they locked her
up but she was trafficking to no one no
accountability Sam bankman freed guy
just oh man he swindled four billion
dollars out of his investors or some
some amount of billions of dollars and
now he but he's still he's sorry he's
speaking at the New York Times right now
you can see really at the New York Times
right now in New York I think he's doing
a it's like a video call yeah if he
steps into U.S soil I imagine that he's
not going to leave I doubt it he made it
he made enough donations to Democrats to
live the rest of his life in comfort and
that's a lot of protection money yeah
dude so he was the CEO of FTX which was
like this this internet
um what would you call it like an
exchange for crypto and then they were
taking people's money and giving them
like a loan and they're holding their
their money as collateral and then he
was like investing their money in like
political campaigns I mean it's the most
hideous misuse of of people's investment
funds like Bernie Madoff stuff yeah I
don't know if you saw there's the guy
that asked him where'd all my two
million dollars in savings go and he's
like oh well I'm sorry about that didn't
yeah
no no he's so disconnected from reality
he was having sex with like nine women
in his uh drug Shields just like all the
elites that's all they do and they were
taking all these different he would
entice his employees to take different
kinds of drugs to see which one they
like the best and help them work the
best his girlfriend's running Alameda
research which is his sister Corporation
that's taking it's like fight funneling
FTX funds and then investing it
um undercover yeah uh what's her name
Caroline uh you guys got her last name
Caroline I don't know man it's important
that these people stay in the media I
think she's a weird looking job yeah I
was gonna say she's the weird looking
woman
it is it is crazy Caroline Ellison is
what people do with power it's a crazy
thing yeah like this this guy for
whatever reason comes into access and
he's like drugs and orgies
like I'm not surprised you know what I
mean like like it reminds me of that
experiment where they gave the rat the
electrode on its brain to trigger
dopamine it's like you give it's almost
like there's aliens and they're like
let's give this random guy a bunch of
money see what he does and he's just
pressing the button on his brain like
this feels good and the corporate media
is like look how humble he is look how
amazing look how nice and down to earth
he is what show was it where like you
look bad it's like an old clip and he's
like physically shaking yeah and I'm
like did nobody questions
ton of drugs absolutely drugs he is
shaking in that interview yeah it's like
at the time nobody nobody noticed that
like he's a literal tweaker yeah my
goodness and then you try you trust this
man because uh Jim Cramer called him the
next JP Morgan and Chase that I mean oh
that was crazy come on guys I like the
account unusual whales they um they
screenshot all of Jim Cramer's takes and
then they just like age so poor he's
blocked them by now but they age so
poorly that it's just so funny well
what's that other Twitter account like
reverse Kramer or something like that
yeah it's like whatever he says do the
opposite and then whenever someone does
something that he said to do they're
like oh they didn't reverse Kramer and
now they lost all their money I look at
Sam's name it's bank man fried like okay
is that an electric chair joke like what
is this simulation that we're in his
name is bank man well his family is all
connected to the Democratic party and
super Pacs that have been funneling a
crap ton of big money into the
Democratic uh establishment yo I'm all
about compassion and forgiveness but at
some point when someone swindles people
out of 4 billion or whatever how many
billions and millions and thousands of
dollars all these people lost to this
one drug addict you know horny 28 year
old nerd check us out let's pull up the
story
from cointelegraph fear of angry people
drove bankman freed to open withdrawals
for bahamians the former FTX CEO has
explained why the exchange only reopened
withdrawals for Bahamian citizens
shortly before filing bankruptcy
basically said the reason he quote the
reason I did it was was critical to The
Exchange being able to have a future
because that's where I am right now and
you do not want to be in a country with
a lot of angry people in it and do not
want your company to be incorporated in
a country with a lot of angry people in
it this this is crazy wow dude this
guy's got to be a patsy you know he's so
out of his depth here there are people
that think that he was like it was a
front a front machine to funnel money in
Ukraine in a better way yeah than to
have a tweaker that's like in his 20s
you know it's like hey let's put him in
front of everything let's let's make him
the Fall Guy here and I I think there's
also a lot of mystery about where a lot
of his money came from because the
company just kind of came out of nowhere
and then they got promoted by everyone
especially in the corporate media a lot
of people are speculating that uh and
this is what I speculated I think like
two weeks ago on my own members area
specifically that the intelligence
agencies took money probably maybe even
from the whole Epstein Saga and just
funneled it into this larger psyop which
some people are saying could be a false
flag in order to bring in more
regulations and control of
cryptocurrencies and Bitcoin so if they
were people were investing money in FTX
FTX was giving it to Alameda Alameda was
donating it that's a way for someone to
technically donate the money but
funneling it through an exchange and
then pretending like that in partnership
with the Ukrainian bank so what FTX was
yes and the world economic Forum here's
what we don't know so but the gist of
the story is FTX takes in a bunch of
money loans it to Alameda Alameda makes
Investments with it who did they invest
with the the chain of the the the the
the the chain of of currency doesn't
stop right there so I have to wonder if
whatever was really going on there's a
third party out there that got away with
everything put it put it this way a
billion dollars goes in FDA let's let me
let me stop let's let's separate them
for legal purpose legal purposes a
billion dollars goes to a company X
company X loans 500 million to to
company y company y then invests a
million uh 10 million dollars in 50
companies
one of those companies is her good
friend who says don't worry when it all
blows over I got your back and now that
companies I said oh we just invested in
this technology we have nothing to do
with anything and that's their
Investments written down to zero sorry
oh geez it's gone and no one's asking
questions about where the money where
the money actually went beyond that it's
like Alameda okay where else did it go
uh well a lot of it got hacked and and
went off the network yeah yeah and when
you say you gotta so they think it was
an Insider but the day the news broke uh
all of a sudden there's a hack in the
network all the money goes to zero and
all these people's accounts and 300
million or 400 million just leaves the
web leaves the network no one knows
where according to the news I like it
says in the article it's like he was hot
on the hackers Trail it's like oh yeah
yeah just before it happened it's um I
don't know exactly who it was because
they shut off all access to systems when
I was halfway through exploring it I've
narrowed it down to eight people I don't
know which one it was but I have a
pretty decent sense he says sounds like
an Insider like if someone has access to
the security systems of the network and
um and then now Sam is saying that he
has a hundred thousand dollars left in
his bank account which to me indicates
he's got money that's not in his bank
account otherwise he would have said to
his name right yeah he put in like he
it's in a shoe box under his mattress
well they had crypto wallets with I mean
I don't want to start making they spent
hundreds of millions of dollars on real
estate not you know so so so they have a
lot of money in assets as well it sounds
like Jurassic Park you know yeah the
dude gets mad and then takes the the
eggs but then the whole park collapses
it's like oh no instead of diagnosed
it's a bunch of tweaking 26 year old
crypto nerds that are just doing
unspeakable things to each other eating
birds and who knows is that what they
were doing well that's what dinosaurs do
I don't know I think dinosaurs were
Birds yeah we have feathers right here
they were vegan yes that's the worst the
news of Allah Sam Beckman freed was
vegan oh that explains it I thought you
meant dinosaurs I was like wait a minute
no Sam penguin you got a problem with
vegans no don't get me started B
deficiency one of the things was like
the drugs he was taking like that M Sam
drug apparently his like it if you're
eating a lot of uh like meat it is uh it
has like interactions that could cause
you to die and seriously that's that's
why the guy like more plates more dates
and a whole breakdown on the drugs he
was taking what's it called M Sam uh M
Sam how many drugs was he on I don't
know the actual number you know but but
what what what did the video say what
else was uh in that video like was there
was there like ssris was this like
psychotics was there uppers downers what
we're talking there's mainly uppers and
things that like the the drug he was
taking they're referring to is called M
Sam and it's a drug that basically
tricks your dopamine system to like
enjoy doing boring Behavior boring tasks
it makes you like it or enjoy it so like
weaponized Adderall
yeah yeah I guess you could say
something like that I don't make sense
his uh his girlfriend Caroline Ellison
who was the CEO of Alameda was saying
that she has less I believe I've heard
this this is all secondhand uh or third
hand or whatever but that she has no
respect for people that won't take drugs
when they work because they just aren't
up they're nice I saw that she said
something about amphetamines yes like
people don't see the world the same way
or something like that crazy just what a
drug adult way to talk it makes you
appreciate how dumb a lot of normal
non-medicated people are wow and and
like if you find out how many people are
medicated how many people are just
popping lateral you'd be shocked I mean
it's all around us like even I won't say
you know who but there are some guests
here that were just like on it and
I mean look look at uh what Jordan
Peterson he was on a whole bunch of
drugs recommending a whole bunch of
drugs and then we saw how that kind of
story played out for for everyone and I
think he's he's not the same person I
think he's a different person I think
he's been damaged by big Pharma uh
something that he's been recommending
for people throughout his entire career
that he became a victim of now which I
hope he sees as a Redemption Arc and and
helps spread the knowledge and
information so more people don't get
hurt like he did Michaela's been pissed
lately I saw a video she's just for
something's been going on she's outraged
about what Jordan has been going what he
went through and and I don't know I
don't know if there's new new evidence
or news about it but I heard her talking
about it it's a crazy time man yeah you
know we need I want you to Imagine This
I want you to imagine you walk in your
kitchen in the morning there's a fresh
pot of coffee there's some bacon on a
plate and some pancakes there's a nice
family they're sitting down for a
wholesome breakfast dad's reading the
newspaper just this calm Serene image of
this like photograph of the the American
Golden Age because now our culture is
fractured everybody hates each other for
every other reason maybe social media is
the problem but I just think about that
that's what I was saying about you know
Trump's speech when he was announcing he
was running make America great again
come back to the point where we care
about our families we felt secure in our
homes and we cared about our communities
because right now we don't feel safe
people in New York I mean are getting
pushed in front of trains like crazy San
Francisco is going to put explosives on
robots everybody's screaming at each
other and hate each other for every
other reason and it's just like man
it's all it's all just like yeah I went
back to Ohio uh last weekend with to
hang out with my family at my parents
house it's really refreshing and I I sit
on the back porch and I'm looking out at
the cemetery beyond our backyard and
thinking like in my whole life I never
was worried that someone was going to
come up here with a gun and shoot me in
my parents back porch and I'll get these
waves of that now it's just like because
it's disgusting maybe it's social media
maybe it's the the high radiation coming
off these screens I don't know there's a
there's a video out of New York
there's a cop just walking down the
street and a guy walks up to him and
just execute something so yeah I saw
that too it's crazy yeah so we got to
figure something out you know this this
story about like ah man
I don't know how you restore
accountability
people should be armed okay well yes
well we have a broken system that that
is built on breaking people like people
are destroyed people are you know
medicating themselves drugging
themselves where they don't even
consciously exist in our human EX in our
in our human life so I I think you know
the problem is not just with diet but
with mental health physical health
spiritual health I think all of it is at
an all-time low and there's a lot of
seething very powerful people sucking
off of that and built a system that they
Empower themselves because of that
suffering and that and and this is why I
think a lot of the suffering is
deliberate and I think they because it's
profitable and I and how else can you
argue it because people medicated happy
and consuming that's yes that's all
short-term dopamine pleasures of things
that don't actually matter and don't
don't mean nothing planned obsolescence
just consumer capitalism where they want
you to buy something that falls apart
they want you to stay depressed so that
your constantly and outside of yourself
for a solution yeah
got the TV or the drug or the sugar or
the the shirt or the like go on these
videos these uh authoritarian utopian
World Views that some people have
what they don't understand is that if
you have a unified culture you don't
need an iron fist if people are working
towards common goals and common
interests if they if they believe and
respect similar things then you don't
need to go and lock someone to force
them China wouldn't need to do the
things they're doing the problem is for
whatever happened whatever whatever it
is everywhere the cohesion is being is
breaking down it's breaking apart the
glue that holds societies together is is
dissolving one of the things yea said
when he came on the show a few days ago
was before the show was like what do I
how do I win a presidential election I
wasn't in the room you guys were talking
about it and you were like I don't know
ballot I like ballot Harvest well at
first I said something like I'm not the
guy for that and then he said you
ignored my question and then I was like
ballot harvesting so but what I really
think we need is a is a is a shared
Vision a belief in in reality like we
need something to live for to believe in
and that's like space elevators and
graphene like we need to excite people
about the future that we can all come
together and believe in and then you're
not going to be worried that your
neighbor's coming over to steal your
chicken you know because we both have a
shared future
so you have the fake version of it like
North Korea where no one really feels
like they're working together they're
being forced to and they hate it but
they do have some kind of uh cultural
cohesion but at the barrel of a gun I
feel like the United States uh if you go
back a while uh if you go back a long
time people people assume that we had it
like when I say like oh you're in the
kitchen and there's breakfast and
everything but there was always some
kind of conflict it's just worse now for
whatever reason and I'm not saying it's
going to get worse I'm actually feeling
like with Elon buying Twitter we could
be moving towards something better and
I'll say this it may be the cohesion is
there but the the narrative is that it's
not for example right Elon did this poll
about rain setting Donald Trump and then
it was like what 52 to 48 yeah and he
said it was interesting to see the Bots
attack then he does another poll should
I reinstate and Grant amnesty and then
at 72 percent now hold on there a minute
how is it that you have this major swing
in opinion it could it be that all the
leftists left because he brought Trump
back or could it be that Bots were more
manipulating public opinion to make it
seem like everyone supported the bunk
and then as soon as and then Elon did
that Trump poll as a test yeah caught
the Bots found their IPs removed them
did another poll as a test cleaned it up
yeah he actually replied to like someone
saying that and then like I I forgot
exactly the reply but like uh
essentially to your point that like that
was a honey honey pot to find the bot
um and the thing is like you you said
the narrative isn't there so to your
point too about the poll the poll for
free speech seventy percent of 72
percent of users support uh reinstating
accounts but there's this narrative out
there for advertisers that they're
scared
um to advertise on the platform because
of hate and disinformation so it isn't
the people that are afraid of all of
this stuff and freedom of speech because
user growth is going up people are using
the platform more and signing up more so
that should excite advertisers it's the
media and everyone else who are trying
to derail this whole thing trying to
drive the narrative but they're losing
they're clearly losing the narrative
um and again they have not reckoned with
the force like Elon before it's been fun
yeah you know yeah everything's been
going on on Twitter has been exciting
it's one this is like one of the best we
is I gotta say like despite all the
weird stuff what what you all need to
understand is as crazy as Monday was
this is like one of the best weeks that
I think we hear like we've ever had just
across the board for one yeah we had
Thanksgiving you know I hope everybody
got to have a good time then we have
this ridiculous show that's all crazy
everybody's losing it but uh watching
the stuff with Elon election
interference we're listening to Twitter
files I'm like man it's been a good week
yeah it's been a lot yeah how are you
enjoying being on on Twitter how has
been the experience of being in Twitter
in jail for so long changed you and how
is this new Twitter affecting you it's
it's just like a like a stimulation
overload I'd describe it because so I
was actually out celebrating like I mean
I was out at my brother's band actually
um when Donald Trump got reinstated so
um right after I was having a bunch of
the House Freedom caucus members like um
texting me saying that they're replying
to Elon telling them to reinstate myself
um 20 minutes later I was reinstated
um after those tweets were sent so it
was like an hour after Trump was
reinstated as the first account after
Trump to be reinstated
um and so like all of that at once
hitting me and then like a couple Days
Later Elon replying to me and it's just
been like absolutely insane and hard to
process it when you came back on Twitter
did you have like how how long ago were
you suspended like two and a half years
it was April 2020. did you have
notifications and like messages from
back then I have a screen so I have a
screenshot uh or like a screen record of
my phone was like I could not use it
because of the amount of notifications
um and I also got this welcome back
Banner from Twitter it was super I'm
like this is a new Twitter that I'm
experiencing but my phone was unusable
for like phone calls and I was trying to
shut like the notifications off so I can
use it but I'm getting texts calls
Charlie Kirk shouted me out right away
Benny shouted me out Jack like all of
these people were shouting me out so I
was gaining I gained so I got suspended
with 85 000 followers
um I now have like 200k so I gained like
almost double what I had in one night so
it was like melting my phone you said
you didn't know what caused it but what
was the ban like what was a situation
around when the yeah so originally so I
posted this meme that they had so Joe
Biden's campaign put up this thing where
you'd post your picture and say uh say
Alex stands with uh Joe Biden it would
be you next to the Joe Biden logo so I
turned it into a meme and I said Xi
Jinping stands with Joe Biden
um so Mike cernovich quoted it back then
and he said uh watch the media spin this
into like manipulated media because that
was a popular thing at the time Dan
scavino had just got hit with like a
video that was out of context supposedly
um so like at 20 minutes after that my
account was suspended so like I put two
and two together I'm like I just posted
this I just saw like his you know
hypothesis of what it could be a
violation and I assumed that was it so
they came out and said that was not the
reason
um and that it was for platform
manipulation and spam without going into
further details and you still have no
details yes so um I would do like the
regular appeals process and I'd get back
different details and like I was saying
earlier so on the day I was reinstated I
actually got one back that said I was in
violation of hateful conduct and
targeted harassment which I've never
engaged in
um so they would just spit back these
random reasons uh and originally Twitter
they said we'll show you the piece of
content that you like violated and which
rule it violated like back in 2015 when
there were it was one sheet of rules and
not a whole page of links so yeah I
don't know the exact violation they have
refused to tell me it's funny back when
it happened so a friend at the White
House reached out to Twitter apparently
trying to get answers and a friend at
the FCC also did they said the quote
from the guy at the FCC is the White
House already reached out on this and
they're pushing back uh they're adamant
that they're you're not going to be left
back on the platform higher ups are that
was from the VP of comms at the time at
the FCC
um at uh Twitter VP of comms to the guy
at the FCC and then now what are you
doing with your newfound uh Fame and and
well joy I've been
I've been enjoying I mean it's only been
I think like
I think it's like nine days now I mean
this this week's been absolutely insane
so it's hard hard to control like the
days and everything but you know it's
been insane what advice do you have for
people that have experienced what you
experienced
um so I've been actually trying to help
get people re-platformed I know it's
it's all at once right now with everyone
being Mass amnesty and everything I've
actually helped I believe get a few
people back on Sven Hernandez and
Marjorie Taylor green so I was
encouraging people because this is the
way I got reinstated is replying to
elon's recent tweets with like a hashtag
bring them back and then also like the
exact username like a lot of the
mistakes people are making is like bring
back XYZ and they're like just putting
their name Elon Musk doesn't know who
those people are people at Twitter don't
know who those people are you have to
tag their username so reply to Elon Musk
or you know people in his Circle
um to get the attention but I think
there's probably going to be more
guidance next week because well this
week they're going to be rolling out
like blue verified and everything so
their focus is on that but there's going
to be more guidance as to like what
smaller accounts need to be uh if they
have to reapply for
um an appeal or how to actually get it
back but right now I think that's the
best way is replying I need I need to
point something out for uh everybody
listening YouTube was having problems
earlier today it was down for for some
people and people are noticing that the
frame rate dropped to like five seconds
five frames per second super slow and
we're talking about the CIA
that's happened before like but this is
what I want to point out there have been
instances where Luke like Luke went more
than one local go off on say like the
CIA and then people watching will see
the video just freeze and like the
loading thing and then it comes back and
Luke's not talking he's talking we're
talking about something else oh my God
there's been a bunch of stuff like that
that has happened before and maybe it's
just nonsense
but uh you know I'm I'm seeing in our
live monitor
something obviously happening yeah
people are actually talking about it our
our tech people are on it I can actually
see
something it doesn't look like it's on
our end but I'm not entirely sure well
the views also dropped off there was
about like four no it's been on the
first night it's been going crazy it was
at like 53 then it dropped down to like
four and I'm like well this is what is
it like 40 000. YouTube's busted let's
put it that way and uh
you know I just had a phone call with
them and uh actually let's talk about
that yeah so uh let me let me pull up
this uh this tweet here
uh that's what I tweeted Google is
trying to get YouTubers to Lobby on
their behalf to protect the current
iteration of section 230. you'll start
to notice videos and social posts
defending it these are not organic I
have another call with Google about it
today that was 12 hours ago and then I
posted at about 5 PM Google
unfortunately canceled my call with them
section 230 is vital to a free and open
internet but big Tech should not be free
to editorialize and be immune at the
same time
so basically what's happened is it is
Gonzalez V Google I I could be getting
it wrong but my understanding is that
YouTube had recommended Terror videos or
something to somebody because it's
automatic right and then they said app
that you provided support to them by by
giving them access to the system or
something that effect or people were
able to search for it and find it and so
you are choosing to recommend it and now
with the Supreme Court granting
um cert whatever the full word is
they're actually going to be hearing
this case and and YouTube's freaking out
I think the reason the guy I think the
reason the guy canceled on me is because
I kind of went off on him I wish I could
hear that conversation but but the issue
is basically that YouTube
is saying no you can't hold us
responsible for what people say which is
the platform
that bans anyone who says things we
don't like and then chooses to highlight
the things we like specifically that's
insane yeah featuring featuring is like
an inherent uh publishing uh tactic and
I think like when it was originally
obviously when it was conceived
um the internet was smaller and
everything
um but I think it was given in good
faith too that they would actually take
action against you know illegal content
because obviously they they knew that
you know they couldn't control
everything that was on the internet at
once and that's why they had a liability
protections is because you know say on
Twitter like thousands of users are
posting every day they can't catch
everything in real time but that's the
thing I believe they gave it to him in
good faith that they were right target
you know the like I was bringing up
earlier the illegal content the most
important and like harmful content
rather than the EU worried about
misinformation or uh hate speech or
whatever they want to say
um that they're going after right now so
I read I read a story about New York
that some of you may have heard me
reference before when they when they
banned public drinking there was a like
a city council member or something who
said
let this law not ever be misconstrued to
say that a man can't enjoy a beer with
his lunch it was specifically about
drunkards strolling about causing
problems well now you can't enjoy a beer
with lunch because the law gets written
and then everyone says oh that's what it
says so you take a look at what happens
with the law in section 230 they're like
hey you can't be held responsible if
someone else posts something and then
they go yeah but can we take stuff off
take stuff down they're like well no
because then you're editorializing yeah
yeah but hold on man like what if
someone posts something illegal I gotta
take it down right oh good point okay so
if you're taking if you're taking things
down that are obscene lewd or or illegal
then you you can take it down and can't
be considered a publisher of content if
you're choosing and they went okay so
now we're going to ban conservatives
that's where we're at yeah obscene is
very very yeah vague word I think I
think antifa's obscene ban them all yeah
they're a lot they're allowed to say
their their ideas whether they're good
or bad and um uh they shouldn't be
allowed to advocate for violence or
organize violent events which they were
doing now that elon's uh in they're
getting banned surprise surprise child
exploitation getting banned yeah it's
really sickening and crazy what was
going on before before they intervened
but I have to wonder at the same time if
this is what we're seeing now with with
Twitter what will happen to YouTube if
they lose not all of their immunity
because this is just about
recommendations do they fall under the
protections what would happen to them
are they going to be able to pick and
choose and play politics that means
Jimmy Kimmel no more you go to the front
page of YouTube No More Mr Beast no more
Jimmy Fallon bye-bye nothing you gotta
search you got to find it reverse
chronological feed baby yeah it should
be a reverse chronological by default
and I think it should be you should be
able to create your own algorithm mine
says this kind of I haven't messed with
it much but you can create your own what
you want to get head like do you like
golf do you like dogs hey I got a crazy
idea if you search for someone you
actually find them right you know like
that's whoa yeah that's a big one there
Google I want I want 10 on that one you
know what I think they'll do is they'll
start recommending channels instead of
videos on the front page you'll go to
the front page and it'll say Mr Beast
it'll say and they'll just say these are
these are channels that other people
have liked and they're not promoting any
speech or recommending speech
then they recommend an individual and if
the individual says something well then
it's like well that's their video and
that's we didn't recommend that video so
I think that's the way it might go so
they'll still keep playing dirty we need
a hard reform on Section 230. Google
should not be held responsible for the
things that any of us here say but they
should not be allowed to suppress the
content at the same time propping up the
ideas they like suppressing the ideas
they don't like that's weird the idea of
suppression because if two people come
to me and they're like here show
everyone my book I'm like well I have to
pick one the one I choose doesn't mean
I'm suppressing the other guy I just
chose the one no no no no no but it
turns out it is a form of suppression I
guess if I'm supposed to be that's not
what I'm saying I respect the point that
if there's limited space and they can
only show some videos then they are
highlighting videos that's suppressing
you if if there's a system where they
say if you get 10 views in 10 minutes
we're going to put you in in the in the
hot new video section and then they go
to you and say except you yeah that's
suppression for sure rules for for
everyone except you you get a special
class of rules that limit what people
can find yeah on Blacklist accounts but
then they're afraid what they're afraid
of is that grandma's going to go to
youtube.com and they're going to see
white nationalism and racism and
militantism and all this stuff they're
like just because it's popular doesn't
mean it's good you know but it might be
the du jour like the thing of the day so
they want to try to curate that front
area for the landing page and that and
that's the challenge imagine if anyone a
man like the the amount of censorship
that we have now imagine if they had
this level of control in speech during
the Civil Rights Movement there'd be no
Civil Rights Movement oh this is
upsetting to people there's protests
it's bad it's aggressive we're gonna
we're gonna silence and shut down you
know they did try they tried stopping
people but people still had
constitutional rights not all of them
were worse protected were as protected
obviously people had the hard these
rights were hard fought but today
because Communications are happening on
private companies they're eliminating
anyone who speaks out and we're not
talking about the the white nationalists
or the neo-nazis because they should be
damned totally
now we're talking about people who
believe in free speech anti-war
activists people who want government
reforms people who oppose a taxation
these are people who are getting shut
down yeah anti-war's big because I was
very against the war in Iraq and I was
very vocal about it on YouTube and
YouTube was so down with it they were
like yeah the people at the time were
also anti-war but that doesn't always
isn't always the case you know in the
Ukraine thing like there's people in the
media that want that they want conflict
over there for some reason they want
like Putin needs to be stopped Putin
needs to be and you're like no well
that's the thing if if you do not want
war in World War III like you saw like
Elon Musk like tweet about it then
you're automatically pro-russia it's
like okay maybe we should go to peace
talks or whatever everyone automatically
paints you as pro-russia it's just
insane that's crazy Elon Musk tries
saying hey guys let's not have war and
then all of the votes are like no we
want war
that I think that was a big moment for
him when he was like okay I Gotta Buy
Twitter man
yeah I don't know though but you know to
go back to the starlink stuff it really
sounds like he's planned this for a long
time but I'm glad to see it I'm glad to
see that you know Twitter is starting to
be improved and fixed and uh Michael
Tracy had a really great tweet he was
like these are the rules from 2015. it
just said don't post in threats of
violence or incitement everything else
that's your problem and he was like we
should go back to that Elon Musk said
make sense but it's got to be imminent
threats of violence Elon make sure
there's a time and a date and a specific
thing like someone coming up and be like
I'm gonna kill you that's not an
imminent threat of violence if they say
I'm gonna kill you on the certain day at
a place then you're creating illegal
activities
threats of violence it's legal to do
vague threats it is legal under the U.S
Constitution you know
if it's not if it's not DMS 2 is like
different from like say if you just
tweeted something randomly that like say
it was like a rap lyric or you know
something like that versus like you're
harassing someone in their DMS saying
you know I'm gonna come and harm you I
think what's the difference exactly
um so one is targeted at another person
rather than just on the platform itself
I would say like if you you mean like a
general post this is like at
yeah I think I think DMS should be I
think those are more serious because
that's more personal
um because that's directing it directly
at you and then the other thing is too
with like public officials too they get
like so many mentions I I forget which
elected official uh pointed this out the
other day that they got like they blamed
Elon Musk essentially for it they're
like this is what speech is allowed on
your platform the problem is it's not
allowed on the platform they don't tell
people to report it rather than like
this elected official will like
screenshot it and put a tweet up the
question is number one if they felt uh
at risk did they contact law enforcement
number one number two did they even
report that to Twitter so how is Twitter
even going to take that down if they
didn't report it so I think one of the
things that Twitter should be doing too
for all of these people that are
complaining is put put the ball back in
their Court say if you don't want to see
Donald Trump's tweets block him here is
the new feature for mutes cause they
have like that mute feature nobody uses
it that's great so yeah so they have um
the hate speech list someone asked they
said what what denotes hate speech and
they said it's not a list I came up with
it's one the company already has why
don't they make that a custom filter on
like the mute button where you can just
toggle that off mute hate speech so the
user gets to choose rather than what he
his philosophy was which like I kind of
disagree with is freedom of speech is
not necessarily freedom of reach but
it's because what they're actually mad
about is not that they see it it's that
you see it they don't want other people
to see these things yeah let's let's
let's jump to this uh this tweet right
here and we'll get in one last segment
for uh for today from k-ron 4 News San
Francisco police clarified that it would
not arm robots with guns instead they
would be equipped with explosives
well okay that's the future I was
looking forward to a robot dog runs up
to you and you go oh God and then it
blows up that's crazy and it would be
like a focused explosion so we're going
One Direction towards its Target and the
robot would probably be fine like I was
playing more Rumba I was driving in my
Tesla the other day and it's got Elon
announced everyone's getting full
self-driving now and it really is crazy
to experience the steering wheel
spinning by itself it just goes it just
Auto updated the car so Elon Tesla
rolled out all full self-driving for
everybody you flick a little tab on the
screen and then all of a sudden your
car's Auto driving
I'm on it's like a three-lane uh six
Lane Highway like three and three and
there's there's a median if you want to
turn because it's a big Highway in the
middle of nowhere you pull into the
median and wait and so this truck pulls
in and stops and I'm and I'm my car
isn't self-driving got my hands on the
wheel and that just slams the brakes on
because it assumed that there was
something in the median coming towards
us I don't even know why and that's very
very dangerous but you know what you can
counteract that by just tapping the
accelerator and it just it cancels the
braking and keeps going that's what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
be like hey you made a mistake car right
now imagine they get a robot dog with a
bomb on it and it makes that kind of
mistake the only difference is it
explodes in front of you and you can't
tap a break to Make It Stop So how you
guys doing we're looking forward to our
San Francisco killer police robot future
what do we got people were masking up
you've got facial recognition is that
part of why we've introduced masks is
because people are they going to be able
to recognize your face with a mask on is
that what they're trying to do uh I
don't know I think they can recognize
you based off your your uh
the way you use a mouse they could find
out who you are and set up a specific
pattern they have gate recognition if
you're wearing a mask and walking it can
see how you're moving and then go we
know that is man the idea that a robot
could walk up to someone and blow them
up on the street is freaking nuts
especially in this country that's
freaking nuts I had a crazy thought
because uh Elon Musk is doing that
neural link update
implant in your brain then we're talking
about X phone and starlink I want you to
imagine this future when you're born the
doctor says do you want us to do the
neural link now yes oh he's getting
norlinked and they put the neural Link
in the brain then as you're getting
older but at this point starlink is
substantially more powerful you are
networked via satellite with your brain
your entire life
so you're walking around you don't have
a phone you're just getting the data
beamed to your brain and you're thinking
back and beaming data back and like
elon's the kind of living foreign
would give the individual the ability to
shut those robot dogs down he's that
kind of Rebel but he's not going to
necessarily be in charge the whole time
perhaps I don't know if Elon would do
that I kind of feel like they'll have
the power to shut you down
you'll be walking around and you'll and
you'll walk into a pastry shop and
you'll say I'll have you're welcome to a
Starbucks I'll have the um egg bites and
the cold brew pumpkin spice and they're
gonna go that'll be five dollars and
you'll go okay
okay just just a minute something's
wrong
uh sorry sir if you can't pay I I don't
I don't understand it's not connecting
what's happening and then report to the
barracks no no all of a sudden you you
get um you hear in your own mind you
have been disconnected for hurtful
thoughts
I got you off you were you were thinking
to the network I'm imagining like if we
get to the point where it is neural link
people are getting brain implants
star links are gonna like yo he's
building more than just one thing you
know what I mean you like think your car
pulls up you get it then you're
connected to the network again no Escape
yeah that's what I said earlier aside up
with the Messiah
um and people could even find someone
through their heartbeat I mean there's
the technology is is advancing so fast
and already it's being abused by so many
powerful people in so many horrible ways
with it becoming more integrated into
our lives we did having more power over
our lives the people screwing us over
with the technology that already exists
will only screw us over even more so you
think it's bad now it's probably going
to get a lot worse I started doing this
thing where I was thinking words instead
of saying them to people like I started
I started making YouTube videos in 06
and I was like well let's just tell all
my past Secrets let's get this out of
the way because they're distracting me
they're getting my mind when trying to
have fluid thoughts so I was like oh my
grandpa used to grab me when I was a kid
and abusive like and I would be all
honest about these horrible things from
my past things that I did and all of a
sudden I had complete control my
thoughts I no longer had racing thoughts
I just have an empty brain where I can
create any words I want at any time for
the most part and I think that's how you
counteract this neural net crap with
them trying to read your thoughts you
don't have any
and then you can make it hear what you
want it to hear that's a perfect
veganism I love it
that was good
um but you know it's funny but you make
a point
uh I don't know how I think the
challenge is it takes a strong
meditative mind to counteract a probe in
your brain you know what I mean like try
and clear your mind and think of nothing
when you also have that Trope of don't
think of a white fence and then you
immediately do and it's like you can't
do anything about it man that's that you
see Ghostbusters when Ray they're like
no one think anything he's like oh no
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man I'm sorry
I'm sorry person that came into my mind
that's Gozer you know don't think about
anything
so I guess I wonder you know are we all
being led by Elon Musk the the Pied
Piper it's like the walrus and the
carpenter and he's dancing around and
we're all dancing along with him about
to go around the corner and get I feel
like he would know that he would see
that in the distance that he would know
that he could be used as a Honeypot so
like he would have some protections
beforehand I'm saying he's doing it on
purpose like I'm saying is it possible
that he's like I'm here for free speech
everyone support me he gets everybody
rallying behind him because he knows
what public opinion is he starts doing
these things that won't stop his
technological advancements or plans and
you know maybe he thinks it'll be a good
thing you know we'll end all the hate
when everyone's wired into each other's
brains it's just confusing what his
motivation would be though like because
like I said earlier it's like what's
money to him like I mean suppose he
wants to do that like
doesn't that like make him even more
busy than he already is like he he just
like owns everything now like yeah would
he be like elected like a ruler at that
point because he would be more powerful
than the government at that point I mean
he wants to go to Mars yeah and and I
was I was talking about this a bit
earlier and I think we talked we may
talk mention it here
we we have
um there are a lot of human beings that
don't contribute uh to anything
I don't think people are uh required or
obligated to contribute to anything
humans are free to go and live on a farm
and live their lives and be happy but if
you're if you're looking at a shared
mission of the United States it's like
so few people are working towards any
kind of shared goal whereas in like
World War II yet basically everybody
working together
so if you're someone like Elon and uh
you want to colonize Mars you want to go
to other planets you you need a
substantially larger amount of active
people working towards this
infrastructure Elon says we need more
people he's right more people means more
Specialties means more technology means
better human better capabilities for men
but we have a lot of people who do
nothing you know like people who are
just like dancing in Times Square now I
got no beef with Times Square dancers I
think this stuff's really cool but it's
not going to contribute for the most
part to any kind of space travel or
world view or World Vision of someone
like Elon Musk
it may be relaxing and fun to watch it
may be entertaining that's good for you
but there's certainly certainly a lot of
people that aren't doing things in the
direction that a powerful individual
might want
so let's assume Elon Musk says it is
imperative that Humanity travels to the
stars because he really believes it
well then of course you would want
massive control over the narrative to to
create a space where everyone is working
towards a goal that he desires what is
money that's a good point Elon can only
buy so much but if you control the
culture of an entire country they will
willfully start building your rocket
ships yeah Manpower that's one of the
greatest things money can get you is
Manpower but people will do that for
free if they believe in you and it's not
and but there's also limits too some
people will be like you can't pay me
enough and I don't need your money you
you make you make a culture or Community
or or a group of people want to do it
and then you don't gotta you don't got
to worry about it excuse me yeah I'm
looking for the sound I'm really looking
forward to interviewing Elon
probably get them on the show pretty
soon I would imagine how busy is over
Twitter HQ can you set it up hey Alex I
mean I mean Ian is very confident
there's often where like Ian will be in
the beginning show like we should get
Brad Pitt on the show
culture crisis too right yeah if we
could confidence plays man it's like I
don't deep down I'm an insecure child
like everything I'm like terrified like
I'm this is all an act you know this
whole Ian Crossland character I've built
but I do believe we had Kanye a couple
days ago like the this is it man we're
coming together and we're gonna build a
space elevator Reach for the Stars
you know
I'm just like Ian how are we supposed to
book these people you know one step at a
time who else do you guys want what
what's the biggest guess do you think
you guys I could love to get Ron Paul on
the show love to I don't know what his
status is how he's feeling we got to go
to Texas yeah we have to go to set it up
let's go there's there's a lot of people
who are work with that are fans of Ron
Paul who have already told us like we
have to go to Texas and we can make
something happen let's set it up let's
do this Ron Elon I'd like to get what
about you Chris uh pavlovsky Bill ottman
Elon Musk like a bunch of CEOs of tech
companies the biggest the biggest guest
for the show what would it be plus
Schwab yeah I would love to sit down
here yeah
come on the show yeah I would love to
talk to Mr Mr klausch and I would love
to talk to Mr Gates as well
um what about you Serge
sorry go ahead no I was gonna say class
is going to be like is there too many
people and says so we have to get rid of
them there's just too many of them who
do you want to see I'd love to speak to
Elon as well just as a South African who
may want to speak to a fellow South
African that's about it yeah I just say
Elon like typically when people are like
who would you rather have on the show
like who do you want to get in the show
I'm like I don't handle booking you know
Cassandra messages and finds people and
before that was Lydia but if I there are
some times where I'll hit somebody up
and be like yo yo come hang out like I'd
love to be on the show Elon definitely
Putin Kim Jong-un all of you guys you
guys have an invite here
would be a spectacular imagine what is
he going through right now I mean does
Kim Jong-un speak English I believe so
he went to Swift schools right right
yeah he does that would I would that's
that's a good point I would absolutely
let's go to Korea to talk to him
why not go to North Korea at the DMZ
yeah yeah yeah
I'll do it we did crazier stuff who
would be your favorite guest to have on
her probably Elon Musk yeah the time is
hot yeah it is well I I just think
elon's doing so much good you know as
much as I mentioned there's like maybe
he's got an agenda and stuff like that
it's because I'm not going to give
anybody a guarantee like I'm not going
to assume trust in anybody but I on the
surface the things that he's doing are
are absolutely admirable 100 and he's
extremely busy so I think the only way
we would be able to do it is if we go to
him set up a studio maybe outside of
Twitter HQ or anything and just like
come in come out right um and and so not
the way yeah at Twitter in and out
really quick they got the infrastructure
we can probably set up a studio in the
building make it reasonable so he
doesn't have to fly or spend a lot of
time we do the show on Twitter we stream
it on Twitter and then Elon tweets it
out and then that's um us having a
fantasy vision of what the best possible
or that's the way that's the way we
launched Twitter's partner program there
it is ah right
um um I am down uh absolutely officially
crossing over officially moving over to
a new platform that's going to be way
better than you know
and
officially launching the you know media
this New Media think about I think so
here imagine this guys for everybody
listening if we were on Twitter and
there was an easy like you go to you go
to twitter.com timcast and then it just
says like live there'll be like a tab
that says live now you click it and then
you'll get this video feed and you can
click retweet yeah that's it yeah think
about how big the show would be if like
everybody just clicked retweet right
there and it got shared to all these
feeds so that's why I'm like I would
absolutely love to stream to Twitter it
exists they don't have you know the
Super Chat function stuff like that but
uh that would be fantastic so that's why
you said to you know I tweeted at Elon I
was like do these things that would be
fantastic it's nuts yeah you can't read
he's probably setting up super chats
like why wouldn't he that's the way of
beating out the advertising on YouTube
that's right we gotta go to super chats
right now as a matter of fact so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com because
we're gonna we're gonna have a members
only show coming up for you around 11
p.m you don't want to miss it but for
the time being we will talk to you guys
so uh let's see what you got graphy says
Peck the like button be the notification
thank you grafty we uh have a shed we
just shipped out to cocktown gonna give
the roosters uh an expanded home oh nice
yeah Winter's coming they need a place
and now they have a big massive thing
coming in so we're really excited
we got too many roosters
um there's a couple that I think are
safe from being consumed like uh Roberto
of course he's the king and Isaac the
son of Sarah he is absolutely uh safe
he's a big dude he's a Brahma the black
stars though that we have so many of
them this is Vanessa and Dorothy's Sons
they're aggressive and they look mighty
edible but Chris does not want to eat
any of them yes
[Laughter]
he doesn't want to eat them he's just
enjoying watching them grow
yeah yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim Bravo to
your segments today call out fools at
the system the website is all use need I
also want to shout out surge.com for
those impressive buttons as of late his
progress is noticeable oh there you go
thank you much Raymond appreciate it
search.com that's the website no that's
just my moniker it's from the DJ days
yeah do you have a website uh I don't I
should ask you to help me do that but I
mean I can figure it out I'm sure that's
easy all right Doomer humor says section
230 should be repealed to bring the
chaos needed for a real conversation
yeah I know I'm kind of like you know
what's funny is um people project their
motivations on other people
that's like a normal thing and so I just
wanna I I just long for that moment
where I can explain to the the clout
Chasers and the trolls on Twitter that
like
if section 230 got nuked and we got
removed from notifications I would just
be laughing as loud as possible
if tomorrow we got cut off from
everything I'd just be like I got my van
ready and there is the river and I'm
gonna go chill I will play Spelunky
until the sun goes down actually I'd
probably play World of Warcraft or
something not bad OG Warcraft again that
always Rogue always you know it's only I
think I like playing when I play a
priest I was playing OverWatch I like
playing Sombra because I like stealth
it's just like the element of surprise
is so effective Genji big fan of Genji's
okay I I like uh the the two characters
I like playing the most are probably
Sombra and and Diva hey worst case
scenario yadiva is nasty she's good in
uh Heroes of the Storm too
um what if they repealed section 230
outright what's like the worst case
possible thing that would start
happening after that
they if there was no section 230 yeah
then YouTube would if if Ward was coming
down that section 230 was going away
YouTube would go to all the major
networks and get a liability waiver from
them they would go to a handful of big
creators and then they would ban
everybody else because they could get
sued yeah yeah they would they would
they would uh they would probably create
yeah that so
it's not about whether you get sued it's
about the fact that YouTube gets sued
100 000 times in a single day and it's
impossible for them to deal with so
section 230 is very important
but I I think that's just like a basic
understanding like YouTube's not
speaking these things we are but section
230 also grants them immunity to
editorialize and promote whoever they
want I disagree that's wrong
if you if you choose to promote someone
then I think you should be responsible
right now Google is giving 13 million
dollars for fact checking and I'm like
if you pay for it you should be
responsible but section 230 says you can
pay for the content
publish on your front page and still be
immune from liability how the does that
make sense
all right let's read some more what we
got
Ron C says
T-Mobile and starlink have announced a
satellite-based service for 2024. you
know I'm so stoked on that
that's great
I mean I guess it'll be uh I guess it'll
be interesting man
Thomas Larson says free mobile phones
the image is even purple the colors and
the plan of the villain from the first
Kingsman movie do you guys see that yeah
I've seen it he gives everybody free uh
phone and like cell connection yeah
that's right and then you can turn on a
device that plays a sound that triggers
the aggression aggression centers of the
brain it makes everyone fight each other
right so that they all kill each other
wow yeah he was like otherwise global
warming is going to wipe us out
creepy good movie though where have I
heard that before
uh a raftus of stat says Ian is going to
ask Elon about graphene and he's already
going to have all the answers and have a
massive sympathetic Crystal on him my my
uh my regret from the other night when
Kanye left is that I didn't run after
him be like graphene we're about to
change one because if he has as his
presidential message we're going to
build a graphene industry and Elon could
get involved too I think it's very
exciting very exciting
Logan Culver says Tim whatever happened
with the freedom phone did you ever get
one to review no
we didn't I have no idea what happened
with that oh wow it's a while ago it was
it was that we we couldn't get one from
them because it would defeat the purpose
of doing a review you can't trust it if
they're handing it to you and we
couldn't have it ordered to our names
because again they'd be like make that
one the good one and we also there was a
huge wait list so we were like I don't
know how we get one like we could have
said hey give us a phone they would have
but then how could you trust the review
is accurate if it's you know a potemkin
phone or something like that um
RN Ricky Bobby says I'd like to request
a shout out a shout out my daughter
Tilly was born November 3rd 14 weeks
early in the Philippines she's not doing
well and I'd like to direct some
attention to give sendago saving baby
Tilly please spread the word and perhaps
some collective Consciousness towards
the well-being of your daughter and that
that Collective energy right Ian yeah
we'll we'll focus it and maybe help her
healing right now healing energies man
I don't know how do you guys believe in
that stuff that when when everybody
focuses thought it has an impact or
something
I fully do sympathetic vibrations real
crystals vibrate other crystals across
the room our bones are made of crystal
like some people call it prayer I was
going to say prayer you could all like
we were talking about earlier when we
were talking about oh
um the Jewish god the Christian God the
Islamic God it's like what we're all
talking about the same thing could be
something similar to that abrahamic God
all right MF Damian says speaking of
covet I thought it was supposed to be
weak now 104 fever and muscles locked up
to where I couldn't walk yesterday
suggest otherwise jeez man nah man Cove
it's a nasty thing dude yeah that's why
I'm just like talk to get a good doctor
man make sure you like when you go for a
contractor or a plumber do you just say
yeah sure whatever or do like read
reviews about them do you ask them
questions make sure they're skilled you
know the doctor is is that same as
anybody else in fact probably more
important I've had I've had dentists
that are like
yikes and I've had some really really
good ones that are great you know
well get well soon man by the way yeah
yeah
all right David Toronto China knew about
it way before that an international
track even there in 2019 a lot of the
track people got sick when they returned
home and there was the military games
too right
I don't know about that Joshua Ryman
says I side with Luke on everything
oh well I would I would vote vote for
Luke I would say don't and no
do your own thinking don't believe
anyone 100 of the time do your own
research do your own homework uh I make
mistakes sometimes everyone does and
independent thought is I and and having
an open mind is the most important thing
that I think Society needs more than
ever
all right Tarzan jungle Kung Fu says
Crowder interviewed him a mortician from
the UK he said the chemical makeup of
the growths didn't match the makeup of a
typical blood clot the difference wasn't
small either if I remember right yeah
I'm wondering what's it made of like
these clots that they're saying they
find in these people that you've seen
these videos what is it you know it's
like a weird spongy like material of
some sort why they didn't just tell us
in that documentary where they were
showing it did they not put it under
microscope and like they should have
yeah but I'm not gonna I'm not I don't
think they had to do anything they did
what they did someone should now go and
do a deeper analysis to figure out what
it is what it's made of specific kind of
protein or something or what is it
collagen gonna say maybe they didn't
have the tech to do so but yeah yeah
what do we got David O'Hare said would
blasting the space rocks with
frequencies like from Red using
frequencies to push it what about it Ian
yeah you could do that
definitely sound waves you could move
stuff with with wave power but sound in
space I was going to say how do you
concentrate that wouldn't it
um maybe you'd need some sort of like
hydrogen to bounce it off of okay cam
girl Asuna says Tim space colonization
will never happen while the
establishment types have power they know
that eventually there would be no
possible way to control everyone if
Humanity's spread through the Galaxy
they will Doom us all to keep that
control also time dilation is an
interesting concept like if we created a
massive vessel to carry a hundred
thousand humans to go colonize Alpha
Centauri or something they'd be like a
quarter of the way there but then on
Earth Technology would have advanced so
far we'd beat him to it you know what I
mean so it's like it's a crazy concept
us presumably technology would advance
that far could you imagine that it's
like a thousand years in the future and
they're like we're gonna go on our
faster than light ship and go look at
the the uh Earth vessel from you know
700 years ago that's they're in hyper
sleep and we can go like when they land
they get out and there's like a billion
people living on the planet and they're
like wait what we're the colonists like
well actually the ethical thing to do
would be to find them in in space and
and hook up with them and then bring
them
yeah I guess yeah
okay what do we have
Ben and Lee says Dr Charles Leiber was
arrested in January 2020 while working
with two Chinese Nationals one of which
was arrested in December 2019 for
stealing vials of biological research we
covered that on this show yeah it was in
Yahoo news they found the viruses in
their bags or whatever and they're
flying in the airplane oh yeah that's
right can I remember that now yep
Defiance says Ian the torrid meteor
stream is an area of Earth's orbit that
we passed through once a year in late
October early November November it's
hypothesized that 12 800 years ago a
torrid meteor caused the younger driest
period though yes it was at the end of
the younger dress we passed through it
twice in a year we passed through to the
end of uh I think it's the end of June
June 30th and at the end of octo early
October end of October so it's twice per
year that we passed through that thing
but not always we're just in the in the
mode right now where we're passing
through it twice a year you don't always
pass through it at least that's what
I've heard from Graham Hancock I could
be misquoting look for him for expertise
Ben Hixson says Tim to see the worst of
Australia please look up Topher field
and see Battleground Melbourne where a
pregnant woman is arrested for
incitement for a social media protest
Post Yeah Yeah exam
that video where a cop pit Maneuvers the
pregnant woman that flips her Carver is
going viral again because she was like
there was barely no there was almost no
shoulder so she's like got her blinkers
on and then he just hits her and then
she flips too and chill man some people
though they just don't want to do it
John Savage says covet has has uh has
shown to affect the respiratory system
whereas the other uh something else may
affect the cardiovascular system we'll
we'll keep that you know we'll do we'll
uh we'll we'll elaborate more on the
members only show because they're
they're upper limits but uh we try we
try so
all right what do we got more Super
chats
what is this how word says let's go
Brandon Dan Elon really Orion show some
love to SBF
some people are pointing out that it's
Randall Carlson that's the expert not
Graham Hancock they're both pretty
awesome either one of those guys are
going to get you there someone's a Jerry
listener waffles Sensei says I bet
vijayagade was crying that day because
of how many Communications Twitter had
to delete that week knowing they
couldn't get rid of it all yeah
seriously man
greater gate holder says Tim got to fact
check you on the cop who got shot from
behind he's actually parking authority
and he's still alive not that it makes
that any better I'm glad to hear he's
alive man that's a crazy video he's a
parking enforcer what is this yeah oh
that's crazy man maybe it was personal
or something
weird where was it Philly
I think it was Philadelphia Philadelphia
yeah man that's crazy dude what's
happening to our country
no but for real though what is happening
to our country
I don't know you guys says asked my
father long ago why there are so many
a-holes in the world he said that there
aren't it's just easier for them to
reach you now uh-huh yeah I think uh
I think people
man
they're they're there are some evil evil
people in this world I'll just put it
that way like evil exists and given the
opportunity it it's it slimes out
wherever it can and I need to only
mention the individual uh who has been
arrested for trafficking to no one
that evil is there and so when you see
someone like Maxwell and that conviction
but they refuse to dig any deeper like
this is this this is where you start
getting into corruption there are there
are federal law enforcement individuals
who know what she was doing and who with
and they're like nah better not say
anything that's evil sorry
total evil oh no but but high-ranking
officials in government would be would
it be so bad for our system no those are
evil people don't let them get away with
it and then I'll I'll add this to it
the capacity for evil is within many
other people
who given the power would jump at the
exact same opportunities that's a scary
thought the only reason some of these
people don't I'll put it this way you
probably know someone who given the
opportunity would gladly take the place
of someone like Maxwell or Epstein
granted all this power a private island
to plane there are people who would do
anything just to just to have that power
and you don't know who it is
yeah that's a scary thing it could be
anybody it could be anybody could be
turned into that too I think some minds
are stronger than others but no one's
impervious he gets a constant diligence
I look at Dylan Radigan you know he quit
and he went hydroponic farming or
something the story of I think was it
Cincinnatus was he the Emperor who was
like I don't want to be Emperor and he
quit I think so that that was his name
maybe yeah um it was an emergency and
they were like Hey we're making you
Emperor and then after the emergency was
over I was like I'm done I don't want to
do this I'm gonna go farm again super
cool story not everybody is like that I
think there's more good than bad but
there's it's comparable it's it's yin
yang it's light and dark it's set in
rods night and day you know what I mean
yeah Dylan was was cool Dylan Radigan of
MSNBC yeah uh very uh you know down to
earth guy I mean were you there when we
were hanging out with him I I hung out
with them a couple times in DC in New
York City after Occupy Wall Street and
then afterwards uh and he's doing some
really cool amazing projects I I think
it'll be worth even potentially if he's
back in the states that have him on
because his transition is really
something and I think what he's working
on is very solution oriented as well and
deserves more attention
all right Taylor says killer police
robots in San Fran are not Uncharted
Territory the Dallas sniper was killed
by a robot delivered bomb in 2016 no
charges for the cops that's right that's
right yeah I was mentioning that uh I
had to segment on it it's not going to
be like a robot dog running around with
a with a gun firing it's gonna be like
someone's going to be ducking behind a
car shooting at cops and the robot's
Gonna Roll Up and then go oh it's going
to blow up or drone bullet a drone yeah
that's that's crazy yeah dude just like
in Ukraine they have bullets in Ukraine
most of the war is being fought with
drones a quadcopter with a small a small
bomb on it yeah and then it'll just fly
over fly it to the person or just drop a
grenade yep yeah that's what they're
doing these radios man that's nasty man
war is awful dude
no joke
yikes
okay
Noah Sanders says neural link equals new
circumcision no baby needs it haha we
never really had that circumcision
conversation is that a good conversation
to have on YouTube I mean I don't know I
don't I think it's like trauma for the
kid it happened to me I was circumcised
that wasn't an invitation to start the
conversation I'm just getting started oh
my God
uh maybe it'll come up in the after show
we may talk about some of this stuff all
right Matt Mill says you're right to him
it'll be kill all others instead of a
watch with drugs it'll be an implant in
your brain also you did nothing wrong in
your show with yay he just didn't want
to be challenged
I want I want to stress this point too
because it's it's like I keep seeing
people not really understand it
two things first and foremost I didn't
interrupt EA like literally didn't
interrupt him I had my hand up then I
made a point when he stopped talking
then Nick interrupted me then yay asked
me a question I calmly started to answer
it he got up and stormed off before the
show everything was effectively
pre-planned peop you know people are
saying maybe you shouldn't have opened
with that article about Pennsylvania
semitism and I'm like I showed him an
hour before the show and said this is a
good launching point for the dinner and
he talked about Pence and there was
there was no issues that's why I think
it was staged maybe maybe not
yeah I got no wheel from it yeah I'm not
mad when you're on a mission from God
you you want to go where you want to go
I don't think I'll ever have anybody
like that on the show again though to be
completely honest you know people were
saying before like you should get yay on
the show and I'm like I don't know about
that but this was a big news thing and
we like doing topical new stuff right
yeah I really want to avoid that's all
the celebrity nonsense it's just it's
just weird
on it I don't know man that's not
something I'm interested in
who am I kidding though it's like you
can't really predict what's gonna happen
like if we had Elon on isn't basically
the similar thing we put ourselves in
the center of some new stuff yeah I want
to talk about Solutions if we can get
the top thinkers and movers in the world
on and around us we should talk about
what technology is coming next how can
we help what's the process cames ojif
says Kim Jong-un and Michael malice make
it happen Tim
every wild if I had that level but I
will I will mention though life is so
much like a video game but in reality
that just means that video games are so
much like life but it really is
interesting how you know we start the
show getting guests is relatively
difficult we're like trying really hard
to get people at a certain level and
we're getting like you know smaller
lesser known individuals and then once
the show gets big enough all of a sudden
we're getting governor candidates and
senators and it's crazy stuff and then
yay so it's like you you you really do
build up level up gain experience points
collect GP and then you know the games
are modeled off of how life is Kim if
you're watching you have an invite
degree is a separation too if you want
to get in contact with him the best
person would be Dennis Rodman so right
right find his guy Kim Jong-un is
sitting down watching the sodium popcorn
he's like pointing at the screen right
now
he's like yes you're gonna get an email
they're gonna be like Luke we want you
to come fly to Pyongyang yep I got it we
got a crazier offer remember
which one uh to another crazy country
you don't want to say it though yeah
well we didn't you did
well yeah then I was like I need you to
come it never happened though all right
let's grab some more but Kim Jong-un
Michael Mouse would be perfect because
he wrote the book he wrote the book
that's true true Seeker events says
level up do governments lie if no carry
on my friend and Live and Die in the
Realms of your ancestors if yes where
does it stop by their fruits ye shall
know them
freedom-bound community
well all right man
Levi Morton says Levi Mortensen said
it's the York's Tim it's the yerks is it
yerks or yerks yerks oh I know the
references from animorph's right because
I was talking about it and I mentioned
that there's like brain slugs that go in
your brain and take over your brain and
I'm like I forgot they're called what
what a fun book series how about that
from the past wow Grizzly nightmare 80
says Tim what's your favorite sg1
episode
oh man I don't know I don't know I I
watched like three episodes a day
because it was on I think Comet the
channel
like a couple years ago there's probably
a handful that I did miss but uh just an
all-around awesome show I couldn't think
of anything off the top of my head Star
Trek's a little bit different there's a
lot of episodes I could think about off
the top of my head that are very very
good or key points that were made but
I'd have to sit down and talk about it
but I will stress that when corn nemec
was here and I watched the cast castle
with him and Ian I was a little heart
sick at the end when Corin nemec walks
out of the out of the castle and then
talks to his fake walkie-talkie and says
Jonas Quinn here we got permission to
build a Stargate and then there's the
portal opening in front of him and I was
just like nostalgic I was like I want
more episodes of that show and it's like
you get a little taste of it with doing
this gag but it's not real I'm like oh
man to see Jonas Quinn going to a
Stargate again we do need a good Sci-Fi
show I think something that Society is
missing right now is a Sci-Fi show to
univ unify Consciousness because if we
can focus on the actual literal
technology being utilized in a TV show
let's make a show called
space hole about a team that travels
space through a hole okay you've signed
me yes he's interested in that kind of
stuff as he shared last night
someone else we should try to get is
Dave Chappelle I think Dave should
probably be also
be incredible to talk to him if we if
yes and Joe Rogan yeah
like it didn't happen before yeah but
look we were in Austin and I think you
were like see if he'll do it exactly and
then I was like well I guess I'll text
him and he was like sure I'll come on by
yeah that's exactly how it happened I'm
like you gotta do this huh you gotta do
this we gotta keep trying you don't know
unless you try life is all about putting
yourself out there and then challenging
yourself and reaching for the biggest
craziest things that you could ever
imagine that's what you're supposed to
do yeah but I wanna that's why I was
like let's get let's get yay yay was
also you know I was like Cassandra we
gotta get yay
and and boom you know man yeah Ian would
say manifestation it's true I don't I
don't I don't like the drama stuff it
doesn't have to be drama with Dave
Chappelle or Elon Musk or Kim Jong-un no
for sure I get it I I'm just saying like
we should we should make sure that we
the people we do have on are actually
are going to chill and have a
conversation you know yeah absolutely
all right my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends all very
important things to help us out and
become a member at timcast.com click
join us we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up should be live
around 10 45 or 11. you can follow the
show at timcastirl everywhere you can
follow me personally at timcast Alx do
you want to shout anything out yeah I'd
have to say my Twitter since I'm back at
Alx follow me on Twitter
I will definitely make sure to follow
you thank you so much for coming that
was a very great conversation really
appreciated everything you brought uh
here to this conversation my website is
Luke uncensored.com I share a lot about
my hippie manifestation powers and a lot
of different stuff today I did a video
about how effed the world is and how to
not get f yourself I'm really proud of
that video I'm proud of my Forum all
great conversations great people on Luke
uncensored.com see you there after this
video follow me Ian Crossland if you'd
like and uh check out timcast.com if you
want to see these shows Tim was talking
about the cast castle with corn nemec
and me and more
um it was very very fun and very funny
very entertaining here's to a future of
space holes let's make it happen I also
want to mention too we have a behind the
scenes video with some commentary about
the trip with yay Nick and Milo as they
came here what happened when I got to
the house we have we filmed a lot of it
so that's going to be up for members
only and we'll post it and then we'll
let you know I think it might be up now
I don't know or tomorrow I have no idea
cool what's happening Serge tell me
about it I I am at search.com everyone
thinks for some reason at the end of the
show when Kanye was walking out where
yay was walking out I said are you
afraid of the press I did not I said are
you referring to the Press because I saw
the miscommunication going on I was just
trying to figure it out do my job you
know so I wanted to clarify that I did
not say are you afraid of the press why
would I say that okay come on like I
just want to say it for the 50 50
billionth time that the reason I think
he planned it was that before the show
everything that he said we had talked
about and he was totally fine with yeah
it was totally normal very relaxing like
you know he was relaxed he was looking
at the story I said things like Elon
Musk Bezos there's a billionaires
there's other people with influence and
he was like yeah whatever and like we're
just chilling when the show turned on he
was all of a sudden angry about it like
it seemed performative I got no beef I'm
not mad I appreciate that yay came on he
he he I appreciate it I I don't agree
with what he said I don't appreciate
what he said but I appreciate that he
gave us an opportunity in the time so it
is what it is yeah all right everybody
we'll see you all uh did you shout out
your search.com or whatever uh at
sir.com follow me on Instagram Twitter
dot com spelled out cool Matt we'll see
everybody else over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out cheers